I'm tweeting and
doing this at the same time.
I just don't feel rushed.
It smells when you tweets,
what?
It really stinks when you do that.
How do you wait?
In what way?
Your fingers smell
the magic finger.
Do you have stinky feet?
Sometimes,
but no,
my fingers never stink.
But that would be the weirdest thing,
man.
If your fucking fingers stunk,
that would be like a major deal breaker.
It's kind of weird.
You've definitely been with a vagina that smells like an arm pay before,
right?
Um,
you have some girls don't smell that really touched my vagina.
Smelling and armpit.
You like that be oh,
smells sounds great.
Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by the fleshlight.
Speaking of Pussy here,
who would you consider it
getting a fleshlight model of your vagina if they offered you a tidy sum,
I would do it for 15 minutes at at the Improv.
I can't do that.
Let's go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight.
Linda the code name Rogan,
and you'll save yourself 15% of the number one sex toy from my,
it's a fucking solid product.
Ladies and gentlemen.
I'll tell you why.
There's nothing will ever say we're in the middle of,
uh,
taken out some new sponsors.
There's nothing will ever sell on the show that we don't believe in it.
And that's something I believe,
start sowing the improv.com then Joe,
because that is the best comedy club ever in a 15 minute spot for Amy Schumer to
become a fleshlight mold.
Sounds like an awesome idea.
Well,
you know,
the emperor's,
I'd have to say if you want to go with like a solid chain of comedy clubs,
don't do it for free.
At least the number one comedy chain across the country.
That's a strong move.
I had a great domain.
They do it right.
Yeah,
they do it right everywhere.
We just did the Improv in Louisville was fucking awesome.
Yeah,
it was the shit.
it was great.
Every improv is just solid as a rock.
They know what the fuck they're doing and every time I should be happy that
they're around,
but not as good as the Pasadena Ice House.
It was a browser and ice house.
Look at,
they're all awesome.
I love the Improv.
I love this place.
I love,
you know,
little comedy clubs like that.
We could support it and we're helping support it with this podcast.
Actually this,
this podcast actually makes the club money,
so it's nice.
It's a,
we do shows here and we pay them rent.
This place is booming lately,
man.
Mark Marin's has been here lately.
Great Club.
It's been here since
19 fucking 50 or something crazy like that.
Yeah.
It's like Europe.
This isn't sane for real.
I do believe it.
Like I think it just celebrated its 50th anniversary.
Not Kidding.
So I was exaggerating,
but only slightly.
That's incredible.
Right?
Is that the goal?
I have no idea.
Anyway,
um,
uh,
we're also sponsored by on at.com on it is a,
a maker of a bunch of different nutritional supplements,
most notably Alpha brain.
That's one that I get mine.
I took two of them right before we do the show.
I take them all the time.
Every time I want to do a set,
I take them if I have anything where we need to form coherent sentences and not
stumble over my words like a retard,
I take them.
I think it works.
If you want to find out about it,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t and Google nootropics.
It's a very fascinating subject,
pros and cons against.
Um,
one thing I will tell you about on it,
when you order something,
the first order your 30 pill bottle,
you have a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't have to return it.
You can eat it all and say it sucks.
I want my money back and you get 100% of your money back.
So that is to,
to try to let people know that the last thing we're trying to do is rip anybody
off.
Making money is second to making sure that no one feels ripped off.
These are all supplements that I use and I have used before I ever in endorsed
this company.
I use them independently.
Um,
uh,
especially the,
a lot of the contents and Alpha brain,
not so much a shroom tech sport and shroom tech immune,
which are really fascinating.
Shroom tech sport being one that actually enhances your body's absorption of
oxygen,
gives you a little bit more endurance and it's got to be 12 in it,
which also gives you a little bit more endurance both of those together.
It's a great combination.
It's based on the quarter steps mushroom,
which they found,
uh,
people in high altitudes where eating to help them cope with the altitude.
And there's a shroom tech immune,
which is a,
another,
a different mushroom supplement frame for your immune system.
And then there is new mood,
which is a five HTP and l trip defend serotonin boosting supplement.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for Alpha brain entering the
code name Rogan,
you'll get 10% off all orders.
All right,
let's go start giggle.
Tell me what you were doing that after the music ready.
Three,
two,
one lunch.
And Amy Schumer's,
that was the worst DJ mix a lot.
I have a whole new set up today.
He doesn't give him practice.
He only does it when we're live on air.
That's when he learns what it does.
What does this one do?
Yeah,
I'm using all new equipment today.
Well you were giggling about before,
are you early?
You're,
you were saying if you can't cope with altitude,
you know,
that helped take one of those pills.
And I'm thinking of about being really high up going,
I can't cope with this and going,
oh here's some new new mood.
Oh it feels scattered.
I wonder if it would work.
You will never know because yeah,
when you,
when you get too high and then if you took something,
how would you know if you just got over being high or if the stuff took it down
a notch,
you would have to,
you'd have to be super experienced,
you know?
And there's also like,
you know how,
how much time had you taken off between that session and the last session?
Because if you just take like five,
six days off and then reset yourself,
you can,
you can get yourself scary high.
You can get,
you know,
if you like,
like we don't realize if you get high every day that you kind of build this like
weird acceptance and tolerance for the high state.
But if you step off for five,
six days a week or so,
do you really?
Oh sorry.
It wasn't my idea.
I told you we just do what your instincts tell you.
Do your instincts tell you like I just got out of the hospital.
You were like,
your friends are doing it.
I did not say that.
It never said it that way.
The kid was begging for weed.
I was like,
listen,
your health is number one.
I was like,
I really,
you guys,
I'd just get out the hospital.
You guys were like,
this will,
this will answer your prayers.
It's good for people to just get all the hospital.
Um,
it's medicine.
Let me ask you what,
what did you,
you said you got food poisoning.
I am a crab cake and Phoenix like a dickhead.
Oh,
as a prep get all the way to Phoenix.
I'm such a
like,
I'm like,
Ooh,
smells good.
And then,
uh,
and like,
you know,
I like new halfway through.
I was like,
Huh,
what?
I'm hungry.
So Howard through like I'm such a fucking worthless.
And then,
um,
and I was like really excited about my show that night.
I was supposed to be at stand up live and I was like all fired up.
I was manic,
I was in the gym with my opener and my friend Jackie,
we're just like dancing.
I was like the show tonight,
David spade was going to come.
I've never met him.
I think he's really funny and it's like cute wrestler and a pro like WWE guy.
Yeah.
And I was just like excited for the show and then I was like,
Ooh.
And then just vacating,
like every hole in my body was getting a ton of use and uh,
until I,
and I still was like,
I'll be able to do the show,
like showering and puking in the shower.
And then,
uh,
finally the club manager came over and was like,
um,
you are dying.
And they took me to the hospital.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
And the doctor was like,
he,
they put me on morphine and all this stuff.
And they were like,
no one ever says like,
so they took me to the hospital doctors like you fucking pussy go home.
Everybody always has like the story.
It's always,
and then the doctor said that you were moments away from 10 more seconds,
you would have been fish food.
No,
we wouldn't have been able to help you.
Literally one more minute if we don't get them to the operating table right now.
Doctor said,
had I not come in,
I would have been uncomfortable for another 10 minutes now.
He was like,
it's good that you came in with diarrhea.
Yeah.
But the thing is when you're that dehydrated,
you can't drink water.
You just puke.
And Pew,
I don't know how people sneak it,
sneak it in,
but they kept me overnight.
And uh,
the woman next to me was so much worse than me.
I felt bad for being there when she was like,
I never saw her,
but she sounded like an old black woman.
And uh,
she was like puking and praying.
So she was like,
like this weird kind of,
and then she's being like,
don't turn your back on me Lord.
Oh.
I was like,
bitch,
he's gone.
He's gone.
She's definitely dead.
Wow.
Holy.
She can really die from food poisoning.
Right?
Yeah.
But I mean,
yeah,
you can,
it happens.
I was in Korea town the other day and it's really scary how many bees and even
sees it.
I think I saw in Korea town,
like it's not normal,
like almost all the restaurants.
And I asked somebody like,
why is there so many B's and C's?
And they're like,
oh,
because we don't have a connection.
You know,
like,
like you know,
in Hollywood it's like,
Hey,
I got this,
here's some extra money,
look the other way.
And
that's exactly what police,
we're not willing to pay them.
Right?
Like if it was some kind of scam that they don't trust our soul,
what does it take to close?
You have to fail like it.
The R D so I don't know.
I've never seen a C.
Yeah,
I don't think I've seen a c I s I think I saw the see what has to happen to get
a seat.
I don't,
I don't know how many died and it be the most mediocre motherfucker.
You look back at like what a Sam meant to you in high school.
I got seasoned shit that I didn't even remotely try it.
Yeah,
that's what's up.
I don't know when that's from.
I think he's probably still safe.
We smelled it.
C a c you get a c just by being there and like the absorbing every 10th we're
having a bathroom.
The fuck man.
To see really
allowed to keep serving food.
Yeah.
Well this was in a place,
but uh,
I'm wondering,
yeah,
well,
you know,
if you go to other countries,
I wonder what that would be like if you went to Singapore and you saw those
street vendors,
you know what,
what do you think they would get?
Excuse me?
Do you know what your rating is in Zag is?
They're just like,
I have no legs.
You're like,
oh,
sorry.
So say people,
a lot of that apparently is going on right now with food trucks and food trucks
have become like an artsy sort of thing.
Yeah.
Like there was a,
there was a food truck festival at this mall near my house.
It was crazy.
It was like all these food trucks pulled up and it was like everybody had a
different theme and you know,
there was a food truck,
it was just waffles,
just guy had crazy waffles with all kinds of different fruit toppings and shit.
And then another one was,
you know,
like really healthy Vegan one.
Another one was this wild,
the,
you know,
Mexican and it's like what they're doing is they're getting away with having
amazing food but not having to pay rent somewhere.
Right.
It's like I've seen those in like San Jose and Austin.
It's like a circus comes to town until they just like fill up and it's like the
trendy,
like you don't need it.
Like we don't need a restaurant.
It's kind of cool.
It really is kind of cool.
I don't want to like what do you do?
You stand there.
Well,
you got a fee out of the problem is the line suck it.
The lines are terrible.
So it takes 20 minutes to get everything.
I'll tell you 20 minutes to get everything,
but you get all these different,
you know,
you're wandering around all these smells like you're walking past.
This dude is making fresh waffles.
Yeah.
You,
you smell the hot syrup of,
you know,
whatever berry sauce,
these porn on it and then you walk by next to that and some Mexican dude is
frying up some Connie Assata and you're like,
God damn,
that smells good.
Cultures Mingle,
Woo.
The all those smells together.
Just,
you know,
that's when you go to a restaurant,
you don't,
you don't get to like walk right by where the food is cooked in that close.
Yeah.
And you're walking by a truck,
you're like 15 feet away from that food.
It's cooking.
It's too real for you.
It's too much reality.
Feel it in my bones.
I think it's cool though.
I think it's cool that they can be like,
they can make like really cool food and they don't have to pay rent somewhere.
Then you have to get a truck one time investment.
Then tweaked to people where they're going to be.
Right.
That's the thing.
It's like speakeasy,
like you have to get the word.
Twitter is so amazing when you think about that.
Follow me on Twitter,
here's where I'm going to be selling my burritos.
Bam.
And then it's like the cool place to go everywhere he goes.
Holy Shit.
That's a fucking brilliant.
That is brilliant.
And there's your screenplay contributing even more and what?
Yeah,
right.
David spade,
you said,
do you know him?
Right.
I just want to wait and we just like kind of met.
I met him before,
you know,
I'm pretty good friends with them,
get them all together.
Have you ever had someone try to pitch you a terrible idea or just pitch you
jokes in conversation?
You're just like,
God,
like really?
They tried to give you jokes aside stage.
They'll just like just slip it in and conversation like,
yeah.
By the way,
you ever think a and you're just like,
please stop a shower.
My mom will do it.
She's like,
your mom.
She like she did the other day.
She talked about how in the bathrooms,
the automatic,
you know you put your hand under the paper towels,
they come out and she just thought it was so funny to walk around the bathroom
trying to get everything and I was like,
mom please,
I'm not,
I'm never going to use anything you give me.
Please imagine if you did all the shit you would take.
What if it became your closing bit?
I'm like,
I love my mom
would never let you let it go.
Never let it go.
I made your closing.
How much did you make last year from doing your stand up and think about how
much better it is with my closing because you're channeling my mom right now.
This went with general in general.
Yeah.
That's what it was.
There was no race behind it.
Just what a con.
I thought the general,
does your mom have harbor secret wants to be not calling your mom con by the
way,
this is the artificial mom
and she won for real.
She's so cool cause that's the only thing.
The only rule she has for me.
I'll talk about everything.
Like I talk about her vagina,
everything on stage,
but I won't,
but she's like,
just don't call me a cunt if I'm there.
So,
so what I say is I'll be like my mom's here at night and I promised I wasn't
going to call her and I'm not going to and she's still after the show.
I was like,
thank you for not doing it.
I'm like,
you're the best.
I love you.
Now she's pretty,
she's pretty cool with letting me talk about whatever.
It's one of the coolest things about having friends that are comedians and you
could actually say that your mother might be,
oh my God and nothing or no comedian even flinches.
I remember you did a roast and you said something about a Patricia's
grandmothers.
I thought it was so funny because I knew that you guys were friends.
Yeah.
Favorite joke to say.
It was really funny.
Silvermen wrote to me after that was like after Gospel Brunch,
like that was her fear was like,
yes,
that was a site.
It was just so silly that you did it.
And it was so much like a bunch of comedians sitting round talking shit to me.
I mean that is completely something that Brian would say if you were eating
breakfast,
right?
Yeah.
When I fucked your mother's brown dirty ass holes
were so you see each other that then when we're out in the world,
I forget,
like last night I went up to the roof of my hotel and I looked around,
I came out to the front and the host goes,
he was like,
he's like,
do you come in the back door?
And I was like,
what?
And he was like the back door.
And I was like,
I said,
are you making like an anal joke?
And he was like,
no.
Like what?
And I was just like,
um,
and it was off a moment,
but I'm like,
I'm not used to talking to people that that wouldn't be okay to say that in
front of me.
So imagine if that's the first words.
That dude says the back door.
I'm like,
all right.
And he's like,
no.
I was like,
oh right.
I'm discussing.
That was his hustle.
Maybe it works.
Maybe worse.
I would probably be that girl.
This guy knows what he wants.
This guy's a go getter and there,
boy,
I could see it.
You can see it.
But now he was like,
no.
Yeah,
it's tough.
Yeah.
It's just tough to like be with normal people.
People get mad when we call a regular folks civilians.
Yeah.
Probably.
That probably is a disrespect to [inaudible].
We were calling them civilians before the war.
Yeah.
I always called them civilians.
We call them siblings in the 80s when were worn at war and there had been no
wars yet in the eighties no,
it never had happened.
All the other wars had been artificial ones.
Right.
The ones that,
like you said,
the conspiracy theories,
zero wars until this last one.
Well,
could you imagine if you could get a culture and take everyone from like age
five and below,
take them and kill everyone else.
So you take all the babies and all the really young kids don't really know what
the fuck is going on yet and then he'd just give him a totally fake history.
CGI,
old writing.
Everybody has their prepared and that's how the Illuminati really take over the
world.
What they do is they kill everybody but babies up to like four after four,
you'd probably have some memories of some shit that went down,
you know?
But I think what you're describing is like what actually without killing people,
like that's what actually happens.
Like everyone's just raised with to ton of lies.
Yeah.
There's a little of that and they're just like unfolding it.
As you get older,
you're like,
oh,
that was all horse shit.
Yeah.
But I think that if you want it to like really recreate a history,
like create a false history,
I think it's possible to do.
I mean it sounds completely ridiculous,
but if you were in a situation,
like if it was like after an asteroid hit and a bunch of people
were killed and there was,
there was very little resources left and then someone decided we're going to
kill everybody but the children and we're going to start society again with a
fake history that I made up.
Yeah.
Which is essentially like with Joseph Smith,
he made up a fake
[inaudible].
Yeah.
Created the Mormons.
I love that.
Write that shit works.
They had a whole state and they're all like so nice and good looking nice.
What's the problem I heard are the f I went to him
Mormon funeral recently and it was the nicest friendliest
were you,
you were allowed in,
I thought to be allowed in that church you had to be more a,
well,
they were UFC fans,
John.
It's all bets are off zero.
Syrians has the religious people were like,
they really love what you just
made that up.
So the real answer is,
yeah,
my friend,
uh,
who,
who dies,
here's your secret Mormon there.
Their family is Mormon.
So they did an alarming thing.
Yeah.
It was,
um,
it was a very,
there are so nice.
This is like one nice person after another.
And even like when you know,
there's,
there's things like when it's,
people write their own speeches,
especially like civilians,
right?
Their own speeches.
You know,
a person who's got a regular job in society that's not like used to writing and
having their stuff.
Yeah.
Heard you can their ego like squeaks out,
know your ego.
Will squeak out when you're talking about people with a past and you know what
happened.
I just,
you know,
weird shit.
You'll find out.
Like,
you know,
when someone reads it,
it's too long and verbose and you know,
you know,
and it's like there's,
there's people that I've,
I've,
I've been to a couple of funerals and the grossest thing that ever happens is
when someone comes up and uses that time to talk about them and talk about their
relationship and how good a friend they were like justifying themselves about,
you know,
to this
daddy.
Most people have at least a moment of that in their speech at funerals.
Like,
I've,
I've only seen people I've seen,
well actually I like,
we're talking about it like it's a set,
but,
uh,
I've Seen Collin Quinn speak at two funerals and he does not do that,
but I think he's the only person I've ever seen that doesn't even have a moment
of,
it's about the cones
where,
God,
that's why he's so funny and so smart.
And so she's so observant,
picks things up.
But,
um,
what I was saying about this,
this funerals that no one did that.
Oh,
okay.
It was really about the person.
No,
none of that.
There was no,
cause the last funeral I had been to him was a Hollywood type affair and I swear
a guy went up that knew the dead person for fucking like three months or
something.
And somehow or another he got on the podium and was like way over doing it and
connecting.
This guy's a funeral with the reason why the son was in a certain position in
the sky and the clouds had parted and I knew it was him.
It was him talking.
I'm like,
fucking get off that podium.
Stupid.
Fuck you can.
He's the sun through the clouds.
You Retard off.
How dare you.
How dare you make me listen to your nonsense at us.
Sit here and listen to this stupid fucking meandering bullshit is poorly thought
out.
How much more offensive at a funeral,
you are the worst human.
And then the guy used it to announce the fucking opening of his movie.
No,
no,
no.
He said tried to claim that this guy's death coincided somehow with the opening
of his movie.
I Shit you not,
which is a blue dog.
No,
no.
We were,
we were sitting there.
We were sitting there and the
dude,
we knew the dude pretty well and we were sitting there.
It was me and three of my friends who knew him when we were just going,
fuck,
fuck.
What is this guy doing?
Like this is crazy.
This guy's going on talking about give the,
give out the exact date of his movie premiere like yes,
like,
and when you go,
he's gonna remember this day and go on rotten tomatoes and give my movie a good
rating.
When the sun part it through those clouds,
that was him talking to me.
He's,
that is why.
Why wouldn't you just talk to you?
He can use his magic to make the clouds and the sun move.
He can make the sun in a certain position and push the clouds away.
She can do that,
but he can't just send you like an email or mail from beyond the grave.
Hey Dude,
I'm dead.
But it's cool.
I'm in heaven now.
Would it be so hard to send a fucking email?
No,
you got to like move trees and shit.
What are you going to do?
You know,
you've got to cause a lightning bolt to land on people.
Have you ever had to give one of his speeches though?
Those speeches?
Socks,
you have shit and it's so gross.
The the dollar.
It's not yourself.
It's not your everyday person.
You have to almost play a character where you're overdoing almost.
It's harder for Comedians I think.
Yeah.
Well I dunno.
I just cried and said some shit that I believed I did.
I didn't,
um,
I didn't write anything out.
I felt like if I wrote anything out then it would just sound like horse shit.
I just tried to say as,
as as much about the person that affected me,
you know,
what's,
what's positive about them and then we just go,
you know,
cherish our time.
It's so,
it's so difficult to think about the fact that your time is not,
it's not,
it's not permanent.
You are only going to get a little bit of this shit and you could waste it.
You can waste sue.
It's shitty thoughts.
You could waste it with,
with doing the wrong thing.
You can raced it with bad energy and it,
sometimes it takes like a death for us to realize that I don't like going to
funerals anymore.
I don't like it.
I don't like the feeling of being around a bunch of people who are mourning.
I like,
there's been a few people that died comics especially where I'm like,
I don't want to be around all my friends that are also fellow comedians and sit
around and cry and about,
I don't want to do that in her life.
I think it's harder seeing comedians upset and maybe it's just cause I'm closer
to them,
but,
but seeing like those guys that I'm close to,
like when they're sad,
it,
it feels so much worse,
you know?
And,
but it,
it also,
like,
I,
I like,
I don't like the funerals,
but then hanging out after and talking with them and just telling stories
because that's what we would all want it if I,
if I died when I die,
I want,
I want people to tell,
uh,
the most fucked up shit that I did.
Right.
You know,
you want people sitting around like,
oh my God,
I'll never forget when he did this and went right because that's what we would
want.
So it's like,
it's also a good opportunity to just like celebrate the shit out of that
person's life and tell every story.
And you know,
there was like a,
at least with them,
with Patrice and a Geraldo,
like,
uh,
like a good number of nights in a row where everyone just was going around just
nonstop and it felt really therapeutic and like what they would have wanted.
They,
they don't want to,
they want people to be upset of course.
But you know,
like,
just talk about maybe some stories and nobody ever heard that.
I did
listen to opie and Anthony after he died.
Yeah.
I went,
I went on day dedicated.
I mean,
like so many shows to him.
Yeah,
it was great.
I couldn't think of any other show that would respect and,
uh,
honor one of their favorite guests the way they did their brothers way they did.
It was so beautiful.
I love them.
They're the best.
They're the nicest fucking guys,
this easiest radio show to do.
Fucking hilarious history.
Hilarious comedians.
But they are just as fast and they kill me.
Anthony's a fucking brilliant.
He kills,
he knows weird shit about weird things and he's,
you know,
he's,
he's a Weirdo.
Fascinating guy.
Fat and Oakland is,
he knows how to move a fucking show.
Jim Norton.
Norton is mine.
I believe he's the funniest guy in radio.
I really do.
Nobody makes me laugh consistently more than him.
He's made trainees exceptable
he'll just say something and it doesn't
so unfazed.
I don't know what would faze me at this point,
but it,
it'll just,
it'll just be some story about like fucking a tranny.
Just
like,
while we're eating eggs and I'm like,
you block it off like a bad child molestation.
You're like,
sounds great.
All right.
She sounds like she really gets you to me.
Nobody else has ever been able to pull off the whole tranny thing.
You do it also people are like,
well you know they like ask for advice like comedy advice and just going on the
road with Jimmy and a towel.
No,
they worked so fucking hard.
They're not like just sitting around doing dog shit all day,
like googling themselves.
They're like writing and thinking and you know,
it's like they work harder than anyone.
Well,
especially when you're on the road and you're trying to piece together a new
act,
which I know Jimmy's had to do a couple of times recently ever.
You put something out,
you got to burn,
start all over again.
Yeah.
I saw him in Austin about a year ago and it was all shit I hadn't seen before
and it was fucking great.
Oh that's so funny.
So funny.
I said to him,
I said,
I was so happy I saw it and I enjoyed it so much because sometimes I feel self
conscious that I have so many Dick Jokes.
You have to pick and choose like Mike am I just,
I have like so many with Dick Jokes but with him every other jokes and Dick
check.
But he finds a different way that you're like,
okay,
I think we can take one more dick joke.
I also realize that um,
I'm very childish and my sense of humor.
My favorite comedians or Joey Diaz,
Joey Diaz is my all time favorite is like the one guy who makes me laugh the
most and then everyone else,
it's like their most childish Shit,
you know?
I like,
I like my shit childish me to the dumbest Shit.
This simplest Norton's talking about someone's sucking hogs and laughing like a
little,
like a silly high school.
What do you call someone?
Like if he'll just use some like old timey.
I felt like a real maroon.
You're like,
what's it like?
No one talks like that.
So funny that he's made having sex with trannies and acceptable thing that could
be a scan of the could ruin your career.
Zero apologies.
Zero.
He doesn't give a shit.
That's a really original thing and it's like just,
and he's not really,
isn't it?
What the original is at Norton?
I don't think Eddie Izzard a sex with trainees,
but he like that's pretty bad ass to where did he do standup in drag?
Yeah,
I think that was more of a gimmick than anything cause I don't even think you
discussed it and now I don't talking about it.
Yeah,
but I mean he didn't discuss the fact that he was wearing women's clothes.
I don't think so.
I think he just went on and I could be mistaken.
Someone will correct me on Twitter by sure.
I was,
that was the thing was that he would just go on stage and do his whole act dress
like a woman just like to freak people out or call attention to himself.
I used to,
didn't used to think that,
you know,
I didn't think about that guy.
Positive or negative until I watched some documentary about him wanting all the
way across the UK.
Oh my God.
It was insane.
He's,
the fucking gun wasn't even in shape and he did like a marathon a day.
He did like 26 miles every day and his feet were falling apart and massive
blisters and everything was open uninfected and he just would tape it up and the
next day brought a fucking marathon.
It's a special kind of crazy right there.
Oh,
it was,
what are you running from Eddie?
No,
well he was wanting for a charity and if he,
if he got dickhead and as he was doing,
he was running for kids with aids.
I'm like,
fuck them.
I'm telling you.
It was really impressive.
I mean,
it was really impressive.
This fucking guy ran,
lacked in Arabic and French also doesn't realize,
he's like,
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't understand.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's some,
a humbling people out there,
right?
I guess dude ranch,
I guess I haven't met him,
but I gotta be out there somewhere.
I'll meet somebody that'll shut me the fuck up,
but not today.
Maybe the best right here.
Every time,
knocking it out of the park.
The funniest thing is there's someone out there that thinks that way and there's
a lot of people,
we know a lot of people like that on,
Bro.
I'm the best I could fix this whole country.
Right,
right.
They're doing it wrong.
I'll fix NASA will fix fucking Rick Santorum.
Fix a mall and you're like,
yeah,
you're the best.
You're the best.
You know what I watched the other day,
best of the best.
Have you ever seen the best of the best way to say,
uh,
Eric,
um,
Roberts movie from like 1989?
Oh my God.
What is,
it's a karate movie.
Hello?
They're in a karate tournament with some,
some other dudes and a,
you know,
they have all these crazy karate fights.
Did he learn how to do karate?
So very rudimentary on Roberts.
That's what happened to him.
That's why he disappeared for a while.
Yeah.
I mean,
it doesn't look like you really learned.
It's not like ever see like Michael Jai white ever see that guy.
The guy who played um,
Mike Tyson in that movie about Tyson.
He was spawn.
You ever see the movie spawn?
I haven't seen any of these movies.
Muscular black,
27 dresses.
No.
What do we do?
This the area committee.
This is it,
dude.
This is such a terrible,
terrible movie.
You never even heard of it.
Yeah.
Tommy Lee,
they couldn't come up with a different name.
Nah,
I think this was before Tommy Lee was famous.
You know,
back then Tommy Lee was still in motley crew,
but better.
Yeah.
James old draws.
A lot of good people are in it.
Am I wrong?
There's the eighties token hot chick with the 80s there's a bunch of respectable
actors in this movie is one of the reasons why it's such a hunk of shit all the
time.
Gold medal winner and heart and soul of the Korean team.
This guy went on to open a Holy Spirit
restaurant.
Korean barbecue.
Perhaps this guy's a knocking it off the charts.
This isn't a scene with Eric Roberts,
unfortunately,
because these guys probably actually know martial arts.
Watching Eric.
Eric Roberts was my favorite celebrity rehab.
I didn't see that one.
Why?
What was his deal?
We'll be like,
we'll just pause.
That's what a fuck though.
His agents like,
uh,
in the morning,
he be like looking at the paper twiddle and his little foot around drinking a
cup of coffee.
Love shakes,
and they're like,
my family isn't talking to me.
He's like,
I'm a little hungry,
but the people like Lee,
I got got it.
Just got to go outside.
It means friends real quick.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
It's like,
oh,
come on.
Stay with the program.
I'm,
I'm gutting it out.
Gutting it out.
He is.
He goes to a chipolte lay.
That's all you got.
You can't get off your morphine.
I'm gutting it out.
I mean,
we touched weed.
I haven't touched weed three days.
Oh,
you're so strong.
I don't think,
I mean pain right now.
There is wrong.
Eric,
you don't think I'm a hurt on the inside right now.
Don't turn your back on me,
Lord.
It became some weird therapeutic thing where he,
he had his stepson and his stepson came on the show.
Oh my God.
Steps.
I hated him for how he treated them.
Like,
Oh God damn too much.
Well,
you know,
you realize,
and this is,
this is a reality of a lot of,
there's a reason why a lot of
people,
famous people's kids become crazy.
Yeah.
It's because when you're like a movie star,
you go places for months at a time.
Right.
You know,
if you're Eric Roberts,
I mean,
I guarantee you that guy had to go places when that guy was a kid.
I don't know if he took his family with him.
I don't know how he rocked it,
but a lot of people just go places.
I know folks that leave their family behind for months.
It seems like that's how it used to be.
Even now,
everybody's so aware and sensitive.
I can't believe that shit still happens.
It still happens for sure.
Yeah.
I think it happened a lot though,
back in the day.
I mean you look,
there's a lot,
I mean,
I don't want to name any names because I'm not trying to,
well,
like who are you talking about?
I'm just looking at it objectively.
Like
when you look at all these famous kids love,
see you like people who were famous in the 70s and the Andes and then the kids
become adults and complete fuck ups.
There's a God damn laundry list to them.
It's a big,
almost all of them.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
Yeah.
So you gotta,
you gotta think like what?
What happened there?
How did this go wrong?
What w how can this be avoided?
Right.
You know,
this is,
this is a,
there's something's going wrong here.
And then the mechanism of,
of raising a human under the,
you know,
this job,
but what is it?
Is it the distance,
the time away?
Is it the unfair and weird treatment that you can,
yeah.
Just having a parent that's a huge narcissist probably isn't awesome.
Yeah,
that probably is an awesome mom line.
Not the best.
You remember mommy dearest?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
It's scary movie.
That was good.
That movie scared the shit out of me that Faye Dunaway is how bad ass.
Gosh,
so good.
She was a bad ass because you believed it would every fucking we don't Dunaway,
wasn't it Joan Collins?
Which one is Faye Dunaway.
Oh,
fait dollars.
There's another one,
right?
Yeah.
Who was a which one?
Oh No.
What's in it?
Mommy dearest?
Was it Joan Collins?
Oh yeah.
Feed Dunaway was like,
wasn't she like Bonnie and Clyde?
You might know.
Well,
I think she was.
No,
it's Faye Dunaway was in mommy dearest Faye Dunaway.
Swami Derris?
Yes.
Oh yes.
Oh,
it's in the family.
Oh my God.
I'm looking at the picture.
Oh,
are you?
I know you remember this.
Of course it's Faye Dunaway
shit.
Oh God.
If you haven't seen this movie and you want to know how crazy actresses really
are capable thing,
this is a real win.
An Oscar.
She must have.
She had to.
She must've that.
She went,
she did it.
She went deep.
If she didn't win an Oscar,
the Oscars are bullshit.
If she didn't win an Oscar for that,
I'm moving to Canada.
If she didn't want to ask you for that right now.
I won't get my bags,
Brian.
I'll consider Hawaii.
I am go,
I'm at least going out of a couple of days to Saint Lucia.
Saint Lucia.
What's done?
Um,
oh,
I just went there with my sister.
That was in my mind or something.
You went through what?
Your sister?
Yeah,
we went to,
um,
I did not know that sandals was a couples resort.
Oh.
So you look,
oh everyone just thought we were raging dykes the whole time.
Wow.
And we look like twins.
So we looked like the most narcissistic lesbians ever.
Like we
saw each other to Barr Lake.
Huh?
Hey,
like how you look?
Um,
everyone hated us.
It was all did,
did,
did you know sandals was all couples like d has that marketing reached you?
I just did not reach me either.
I didn't really actually know.
I actually have thought about like,
Hey,
all resort thing where they pay you pay one thing.
You don't have to pave.
We,
that's what we did.
And uh,
she's married,
I'm single.
I'm not trying to hook up with like,
you know,
like an islander.
Um,
but whatever we,
but it was a hundred percent couples.
We were the only people and it was really uncomfortable because people are
either mad we were there or way overly talking to us so that we knew how
tolerant they were of lesbians.
Like they'd be like,
stop having so much fun.
You too.
And thank you for accepting our lifestyle.
We're sister,
but we did,
everybody did everything.
We were the biggest assholes.
We did everything that the couples did.
So we like went to all the like dinners and um,
uh,
like if the photo shoots inside like a heart shape rose pedals on the beach,
like we held each other.
I put,
I put some pictures on Twitter,
but it was,
uh,
it was pretty brutal.
Should finger blasted her.
Oh,
I fucked her.
She got her,
she got good and fucked.
Sorry.
This is not just lesbian sex is assessed a lot of game of Thrones.
I'm anything goes.
It's just started watching it.
How far are you two episodes?
Oh,
I'm jealous.
I was at the even seen it.
Did you like the wire here?
It's what Conan the barbarian should have been.
Show's so good.
So jealousy.
You have so much time to work.
See,
when you go to that Conan movie,
they had good intentions,
but you can't tell Conan story in,
in in an hour and a half.
The Real Robert he Howard books with these long Sagas of adventure and betrayal
and sorcery and and fucking demons and sword fights and shit in like two hours.
You can't do that in a movie,
man.
You,
the only way you're going to rock that is if you have a series like this.
Game of Thrones is the best fucking good dude.
Good show.
At least the first two episodes gets better and better.
I want more fucking supernatural.
You fucks
the supernatural.
You start off the whole show,
get me all roped up and you supernatural.
I want to see a little bit more of this supernatural.
There's one I'm looking for a little less incest.
One more where we disagree.
I want more incest.
Also,
it's like the wild brother and sister fucking being surprised
the way
probably is how they used to do it
gets even crazier.
I don't even want to know.
And that's actually reality by the way.
That's what people were doing.
They were fucking their sisters until like a week ago.
I was in Birmingham.
That shit is still going on.
I saw some eyes,
place to God knows where
people are fucking whatever they can,
you know.
And if you can fuck your sister and no one's gonna know,
hey,
save gas,
fuck your sister.
Where's that bumper sticker?
Let's make a deal.
You want from Dick?
I want to pussy.
I got a dick.
God Damn.
Why are we got to outsource?
I really wonder how many relationships are are like boy,
like brothers,
sister relationships.
I bet it's a lot
everywhere.
Like if you take in the whole United States,
I bet there are a lot of brothers.
The ultimate form of keeping it local,
keep it real,
keep it local by local.
Made local products.
They're really,
it's a,
it's a sick feeling,
right?
Incest is a sick feeling.
Like the idea that people would do that.
Maybe that's why the idea of nationalism is such a bizarre fucking feeling.
Nationalism.
Someone really being into being from one country.
Keep it local.
American rod here.
I'll play it a little more.
Cause there's a Toby Keith song there's made in America and it's all about he
pay a little more,
but it's made in America.
Relax Toby.
I would like it if it was amazing there.
Oh there's another guy who is Keith urban on the country.
I wouldn't mind if things are made in other countries if I thought that people
were getting paid.
The only thing about America is like if you buy a corvette,
you know that someone's got a pension.
You know that.
You know that the people that are making her in the auto union,
you know,
you really do know how much they get paid.
You can find out and you buy Nike's.
You know,
it's like some child,
they bound their hands,
their fingers,
so they wouldn't grow.
If you buy like Foxconn products,
if you buy I iPhones are a lot of other cell phones.
You know there,
there's a huge debate right now they're trying to figure out how,
how to straighten this out in the eyes of the people because they've in a ton of
suicides and you know,
their thoughts are on,
yeah,
they've got a lot of suicides,
so much so that install suicide nets,
what staff suicide nets at the Fox on building and people would try to talk you
through this.
So hilarious.
Like,
well statistically that's actually less than the number of suicides in the
population in that area.
And you're like,
first of all,
that's,
that's a ridiculous thing because what you're saying is that the whole time
they're alive when they would commit suicide.
No.
How many people kill themselves at work,
at work,
at work in the place that they hate the most?
Yeah.
That's your,
you're talking about a completely different experience talking about people that
are living on campus and our proxy throwing themselves off the fucking roof and
smashing their brains onto the concrete and the pain.
We don't,
we can't find the combat is statistically less than would be had they been
slaves.
Yeah,
it's,
it's weird.
But that's the only way you're going to get a cell phone.
They don't know if there's no other way.
I mean,
they've tried to figure
out how to,
you know,
make them in other countries.
And I know they started making iPhones in Brazil.
They make some stuff in Korea,
South Korea where they,
you know,
they don't,
they don't have anything remotely like a,
what they got going on in China.
Would you ever hire Foxcom for like a small job,
like stuffing envelopes or something like that?
Because lately I was wondering really how cheap it would be if I just had them
do like small things.
I A lot,
there's a lot of that started factories in China.
Um,
and they started factories in China.
Like I know a dude who makes pool cue cases out there and he lives in China.
Yeah,
I guess,
I don't know why you decided,
but he's an American guy and they,
you know,
they'll,
their manufacturing is like good out there and get good skilled craftsmen and
you know,
it's a way cheaper for them and they,
they can make a ton of profit,
you know?
And I think a lot of them get over there and they actually like it too,
so
I don't know.
But it's,
I don't,
I just don't,
yeah,
we like living in China.
I think a lot of white guys do.
If I've talked to a bunch of white
guys that have been to China and they say that Chinese girls like,
Whoa,
this is weird.
Look at this white guy.
I like him.
I think it makes sense.
I think like all dudes are going to wind up with Asian chicks.
Really?
Yeah.
Like how many dudes have you lost the Asian chicks?
Um,
well I haven't lost anybody but no,
no one,
no.
But one guy that I dated for like years is engaged to,
well she's,
she's Indian,
but that's Asia.
Yeah.
But um,
it makes sense.
Like there was like a whole wave of like black chicks being like white women are
taking,
are men and they like have asses or something.
Uh,
but now it's like,
I don't think we're a real threat,
I think is Asian chick is where,
but he's going to wind down,
it's like going back to an iPhone three do an iPhone five
yeah,
it's a,
I have nothing.
I can't compete with an Asian chick.
There is nothing grosser than that white woman,
white women are taken are men
attitude.
You can't like who the fuck you like in the black eyes are supposed to like you
supposed to like you more.
That attitude is the very reason why white girls are preferred by those black
guys because white girls aren't going to be as crazy angry and you know,
why does mother fucking time to go out with my time
flag being mad like,
oh if the card pulled up more,
I could've parked like somebody else would have still gotten that space.
Like that black guy does not want you
regardless of what race is happening opened that racism is in the in comparison
to the other way around.
Don't they know we've done that with so much.
If it was the other way around and people,
you know,
if it was a bunch of,
uh,
white girls that were complaining that some girls getting fucked by a black guy,
yeah.
You know,
that would be,
you know,
there'll be a completely different things and that would be like KKK and this is
like,
you know,
hey Chris,
it's interesting that it's,
you can say like,
why are these white women got up?
Fuck on man.
You can say that you were a black charger.
I do think with,
um,
I have no anger about the Asian chick thing,
but I do think,
um,
like I'm,
I'm half,
but it makes sense like the guy's gravitating toward them because just the way
it used to be,
like you used to be with a man because like,
he made a living and you,
you kind of needed him and you looked at him like,
I need you,
uh,
and easy lowered your voice.
I feel like that's how like women talk.
They're just like,
I love you.
Do you want dinner?
Um,
you know,
I'm like,
well,
what about me?
Uh,
but it checks,
you know,
like there's,
they're from Asia,
this isn't there,
this isn't their first language.
And they come here and they kind of need you and they're like quiet and they
like have smaller pussies.
Oh,
so what is really small?
What am I,
what am I going to do?
Bring to the table.
I've gotten zero like I've gotten here,
like getting happy.
You're like,
I need an Asian chick.
This Asian girl in high school,
her name was,
I don't know if I should say there's now,
her name was [inaudible],
which was also a video game company in the 90s which so she's awesome.
Her name,
uh,
because he's what he was trying to find her.
You want her back in his life because I've,
maybe I've changed it to a different video.
Came back,
it was a pocket,
it was a,
it was a video game company that was popular in the nineties so name was donkey
Kong notice.
But all the boys are boys.
The guys liked her because of video games were really popular in the 90s so she
had did like this extra kind of glow to her.
And people because of her name.
Yeah.
She told me,
she told me once,
I grew up in a test city.
Yeah.
The government has literally,
he literally would test this year.
It's true.
Test Him and I'm pretty sure a parts of his life were um,
actually artificially created by the government.
Yeah.
Angel.
A lot about you.
Yeah.
He's like a test subject.
He got cereal that no one else got failing the test right now.
There's no failing.
He is what he is.
You can't have fell out all.
Look how sweet you are with them.
That's true.
You can't fail that test.
They cheat.
The government just wants to know what's going on in there.
[inaudible] told me that,
that they're pussies are tighter because we,
they kneel all day cause the kneel tightens up the pussy.
Did you guys,
do you mind if I do the wo wrestle this show from a dope
we calling under our desk trying to tie number two.
You might just take a quick,
can we just move this mic down?
Nope.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't think you imagine if that's all you had to do.
And women just found that out so they started kneeling for the banks.
Every bit I'm on the subway like,
oh no,
I don't need to seat,
just try to keep Bob happy.
It'd be like a big joke.
Yeah.
You wouldn't be able to hide it.
You know if feel like when you get fake clear,
you can't pretend you didn't get fake tits.
So one day your flat and the next day the huge,
hey,
I'm just trying to keep my husband happy.
Yeah.
It's the same thing Neil everywhere.
I don't know.
Is that what it is?
I don't,
there's a lot of different reasons.
I'm sure I'm forgetting implants.
Yeah.
Oh God.
I'm not doing it.
I think I'm never going to get any work done.
We're going to get any work done.
No.
Um,
you don't need to,
I mean like I,
I drank,
so I'm probably gonna age like dog shit,
but I'm just going to let you and hit the,
yeah,
you got
to just let it ride.
Tara Reid style.
Maybe shave off a little off your shoulders.
You like,
it looks like you got those things in like a suit jacket.
The cushions,
but in your shoulder.
Yeah.
It looks like what?
What are they called?
The shoulder pads.
It looks like you have shoulder pads on your shoulders,
so maybe just get a little bit of shaved off for it there.
Oh,
I play volleyball.
that told her to get her shoulder shaved off.
Can you manage it?
If it was that easy?
It's like you've got too much muscle here.
It was just that carved this away.
Ooh.
Can you imagine like to your body.
I know I played volleyball and I think that it,
I like how I look.
Eat a dick.
I was just kidding.
All right.
Brian doesn't,
he doesn't like to be around women that he's pretty sure could kick his ass.
That's really what fucks him up.
We had Ronda Rousey in here.
She know who she is.
Strikeforce women's MMA champion.
Oh Shit.
She's a beast and Brian
scared to give her a hug and she's like,
get over yard.
I won't buy it.
I used to do it at the end,
like a proper gentleman at the beginning.
I don't do hug
her.
He was so cute.
It was adorable.
He was so terrified of her.
It was like he was in the room with a tiger that he wanted a pet,
but he was too scared to
Rhonda,
by the way,
one of the coolest fucking people.
She's strikingly beautiful.
She's gorgeous.
She's not even a debate.
She's a 10 yeah,
and she's a killer.
She was a a a women's Olympic judo medalist.
She meddled in the Olympics.
I think she was the first woman to ever win a medal in the Olympics.
In judo.
No.
Nobody busted a move.
Well,
I'm married and Brian is terrified of her naked or not.
Eddie Bravo's getting
her in her underwear so we can see what's she's hot as fuck.
That's a killer.
Do what's that press conference she broke?
The girls are,
and when their last fight
the girl didn't tap and so she snapped her arm.
She's young.
She's only 25
that's not her either.
That's
a killer.
Grow.
Go down to that picture,
dude.
Are you going to do a video?
I don't think you've got to find the video highlight reel.
I love her.
What a nightmare.
A hot chick that could beat the fuck out of.
When is she coming back on Joe?
We'll work on something.
She just won the title.
I'd like to do this stuff.
We'll do this
snap.
I don't watch this.
She brought,
she's broken a couple of girls arms.
I'm just going to look at you Amy and started.
We're lucky,
right?
It's why you are fries when a Shitty,
she's a beast.
She is.
I love her.
She's a bad ass it fucking jail.
Whoa.
Look at that and this is in the Song Song Austin,
isn't it?
No,
it's not you asshole.
She actually filmed and edited this,
these arm bars.
This is nasty shit.
See in in judo they stand you up way quicker than they do in MMA or even in
Jujitsu though they don't really stand you up usually Jujitsu,
but in,
in judo they have to go for their submissions really quickly because once they
get to the ground they got to get,
they've got to get a submission on before the referee gets to them and she
developed the ability to snap armbars bars on people with lightening speed and I
don't think any of these girls are ready for that shit.
They just,
she's so good at it.
Everybody else takes way more time to go for shit.
She's just got a few techniques like especially armbars just completely locked
down and when you roll with her,
it's almost just a matter of time before she gets one of those on you because
you're probably not used to anybody having the kind of submissions that she has
where they just,
she explodes on you.
She's strong as fuck and she's super tactical.
Look at that arm bar you see,
how do you see how,
watch that,
but just back that up a second.
This is like no space in between her body and that girls face as she moves
around.
When she locks this chick down,
she starts beating on her and as soon as she has this song,
what's that?
See how fast that goes.
Yeah.
She swung that leg over fish.
She knew exactly where her face was,
clamped that shit down.
There was no air in there.
That was death.
There was no getting out.
I just think she's really pouty lips.
Yeah.
She wanted to make out with you,
which you go last boat for a little bit.
Yes.
Yeah.
You would?
Wow.
I think you'd have to.
Yeah.
I,
I've never worked with a girl,
but I get like major girl crushes.
I.
I've never hooked up with a girl.
But you're opening up your idea.
Do you want to,
I hope I'm like at least hook up with a girl,
but at least once I can arrange that.
Like the hottest girl ever.
I can let you choose from a book.
No,
I like girls.
I'm going to get crabs.
Oh yeah.
Whatever he's going,
Mr Lobster.
Brian,
I'm not going to use that money.
All you can eat me.
You're not setting me up with anybody.
Yeah,
I would say no.
Don't want to do that.
No,
that's not happening to me.
I'm your filter.
I'm going to just be real with you.
I'm going to be real with you.
Either of you at all.
Do you want to go camping this weekend?
A little bit.
The ones who got you?
Hi.
How can I remember?
I remember being like,
I just had it.
I saw the bruise from the IB in my arm and you guys were like,
you need this?
And I was like,
no,
and I,
and then I said yes right before you blew all the in my face.
I could tell you were getting into that.
I was like,
just give it to me and don't blow this smiley face.
You guys are the worst,
right?
Aren't you glad you did?
It felt good,
right?
You don't feel sick or anything?
No.
I feel fine.
This weed is so strong that we hotbox Fitzsimmons back here and he went on stage
high and he couldn't remember his act.
Oh,
I would love to see him.
Hi.
Was He,
did you see it?
Huh?
Yeah,
I've been how it Greg before?
Let me see.
He's essentially,
I don't know if he talks about,
I know he was smoking pot for a little while,
but then he stopped doing that too.
But he,
he went for,
when I met him,
he was an alcoholic when we were like 21 together and then he,
um,
he quit it like instantly just cold Turkey.
Wow.
Yeah.
No Aa.
Did he have something happen?
No,
I just decided to,
this is fucking up his life.
Yeah.
It was pretty smart about it.
But then later he realized that he could smoke pot wherein,
you know,
because if you talk to like a doctor drew type character,
they'll tell you,
you can't do that.
They'll tell you that you can't.
What?
Dalton.
Dalton,
any substances.
Yeah.
But some people even have,
uh,
you know,
look,
I don't want to ever encourage anybody to even try this,
but I know that some people used to be alcoholics,
took a long time off drinking and then began drinking casually.
Really?
Yes.
Nobody have done it well,
yeah.
Well I think so.
I think there's different levels of alcoholism.
That's what we have to realize.
There's some physiological connections.
Like there's some people,
they just have that gene,
whatever that wacky gene is and they can't drink at all.
Or they will go off,
they'll go off the rails.
And then there's other folks that,
it was a compulsion and it could have been beating off,
it could have been gambling,
it could have been a million different things,
but it happened to be drinking.
And then they realize that this is a,
an issue that they have with their own psychology.
And then slowly over time they evolve it.
And then one day they were at a party and have a glass of wine and they're fine
and they don't want to go out and get cocaine and beat people up.
And you know,
why not?
The Germans don't drink.
So like because they are,
you know,
because they were too hard.
And alcoholics.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I feel like most of the time I'm like the only comic drinking.
Well,
I'm happy when I see a guy like that's how,
that's how it seems like it's so focused now.
Clean is,
Norton has been cleaned though since he was right.
But I,
I like very much likes with sermons.
Really.
Yeah.
I worked with him a bunch of shit.
I had never knew.
I never knew any of those guys when they hurt were boozing.
I wonder what,
even if I knew a tell a little bit,
but I never like saw him like wasted or anything like that.
Yeah.
I've seen him wasted.
I've seen him wasted at the Improv.
Yeah,
it was,
it's nice to see a guy figure out,
well this is not good for me.
Yeah.
That's probably better to not take this back on that up in an alley.
I've always been,
even when I was a drinker,
you know,
like when I,
when I didn't smoke pot and I only would,
you know,
drink on weekends or whatever I would do,
it was never something that I had to do and just,
yeah.
Could do it or not do it.
Yeah.
But we all know somebody that's not like that.
We all know that one dude that's just itching for that drink all,
it's fun to be around them.
Worse when they get off and then they,
they,
they start drinking like right away
and they don't realize that it's not like that for you.
All right.
You know,
like I,
my friend who who is now sober,
like we would go out and you'd be like,
let's get a shot and a beer.
And I'd be like,
okay.
And then right away he's like,
all right,
no shot.
And you're like,
oh,
drinking is different for us.
I'm not going to shock people.
I didn't want to do a shot.
Especially on Tuesdays.
Yeah.
Tuesday,
drunks.
That's,
that's uh,
you know,
I'm more of a light beer Miller lite drinker,
like I'll just drink like,
it's almost like water,
you know,
to me.
Yeah.
It's just like,
I'm like a beer at west.
I like
doing shots too and we'd have shows and stuff and we're just all being,
you know,
hanging out around the other one out.
But just drinking for the sake of drinking.
I kind of got tired of that a long time ago.
You know drinking does facilitate great conversation though.
You have some fucking fun loose conversations when you're around a bunch of
people that can handle the handle their liquor.
You know you have three or four beers and everybody starts laughing and it'd be
unfriendly as long as you're only around that right
person in the mix.
That's just like,
just has that kind of Zombie just difference.
It's,
it ruins it like I am,
we're so sensitive to other people's energy.
Yeah.
That if there's that one person and it's also the same kind of pre people where
it's just like never enough for them.
You'll be out till four in the morning and you're like all right and they're
like you're leaving now.
You're like,
yeah cause I'm like an adult.
I'm trying to live my life.
Yeah.
I really don't like the really pushy five o'clock in the morning party people
does an after hours.
I've been doing that lately though like last week or so.
But it's just comedy store shit cause comedy store,
they go rock and all night long.
Don Buress is on stage just doing crazy shit once in a while.
I think that's fun.
Yeah.
But,
but I don't know
best part about the comedy store.
Yeah.
Late night.
Hang in that back parking lot.
Yeah.
And they said that back parking lot should be a goddamn satcom.
It should.
Yeah.
Is it the comedy store,
like the seller,
like it's a work comics or not really is
the ownership is a mass people running in our mass,
but the,
the what,
what the place is though,
what it represents is like,
you know what I mean?
One of the oldest clubs in the country,
one of the oldest in Hollywood and with great history of like so many comedians,
so many of comedians started out there.
And I,
I started out there really,
I mean,
I didn't start out there,
but I got good there.
That's where I became a real comedian,
the comedy store for sure.
I had done it before that,
but,
uh,
I think it was my time at the comedy store when I was just on TV when I,
when I really started dedicated myself to stand up,
that that was the,
that's the place that helped me develop cause it's so fucked up there.
Ari and I were just talking about this last night that,
um,
you know,
he was talking about how he just started a,
Ari's got like a Arash fears all these headline and gigs.
Now he's fucking selling places out and he's really good.
This podcast.
Yeah.
It's because of this podcast and his podcast.
It's just really what it was,
is just people weren't aware of them.
Right.
You know,
and now they're aware of them now.
And uh,
I talked about him with,
I'm like,
it's so good that it's happening to you now because you've been doing standup
for 10 years.
Yeah.
He's ready.
And he's being in front of the craziest crowds ever.
He's been in front of my crowds,
which are like UFC fans.
It was,
first it was UFC fans then became podcast fans were just fucking savages,
you know.
And,
and then it's the store.
He's at the store in front of maniacs.
I mean it's the,
that is like the,
the vortex on sunset.
We're all the nutty fucking people come.
I mean Brian,
Brian used to film people backstage and that we,
we filmed like a hooker,
came back and told her exactly,
told us exactly how she ran her business and like explain some stuff that we had
a guy come back that told us he was the Holy Spirit.
I mean like every week we'd meet some new fucking crazy person in that.
They're really crazy.
That sunset strip is the epicenter of crazy in this country.
That's sunset strip.
There was a deer.
Scary difference to the dude.
It's at the store that comes by with the cross.
He puts himself
cross.
He's not,
he doesn't come around anymore.
Now we actually have a way better Jesus.
Oh,
he's a nice guy.
I Hollywood,
Jesus.
He did a Hollywood Jesus.
He would,
they would,
they would have these kids and they would all be like yelling out different
passages in the Bible while one guy was strapped to a cross of wooden cross.
And they were walking down the street with him saying,
he died for your sins.
He died for,
it was fucking crazy.
And they would always stop right in front of the store and proselytize.
They would stop right there.
It would
figure,
well,
this is the place that we're going to fix the world right here.
We're going to find these fucking dirty comedians.
Pot the worst.
Yeah,
the worst entertainers,
the most depraved entertainers in la for sure.
Standup comedians at the store and they would stop by and yeah,
it was,
it was a really,
really bizarre place.
It would have made for an amazing,
uh,
they tried to do a reality show on it,
but it was mostly just following Pauline around.
It was harsh realities.
Pauly shore.
Remember him?
I saw some last night.
Did you see nice to you?
Yeah.
Did you guys hug or did you just shake hands?
Kiss on the lips.
What'd you do?
How'd you deal with it?
Shake hands.
Hug or shake hands.
Shake.
Hands to hug.
No,
I think I just said Hi.
I don't even think,
no touching.
Ooh,
maybe I don't remember though.
I could be telling her you don't remember,
you might've been raped again,
I'm not thinking of it.
You take a Dick,
sometimes you have folks pick them up in the middle of the night because he's
part of the,
the Columbus thing.
You,
you leave Columbus but you never really leave Columbus cause the aliens will
come and do additional research on you.
So that's Brian's.
Yeah,
exactly.
Which I'll be there May 17th yeah.
You gotta be there with Joey Diaz?
Yeah.
It's a Joey Diaz and Brian Red band world tour.
And when he gets out of the second show,
because the first show sold out,
so go to desktop.
Can I smell a man selling
out?
Can I say,
yeah,
go ahead and say your thing.
Well,
I,
I'm looking at my phone calendar.
Your phone getting high and your website.
Yeah,
I've got it.
Okay.
It's hit Tampa next weekend and in Denver,
comedy works the weekend of the 27th oh dude,
you have a cool site.
It's,
you look at a black art and once a month,
this is my favorite thing I've got going on.
I'm at the Riviera at the starlight room.
Uh,
yeah.
I've got once a month.
I'm there Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
That's fun.
I love,
I'm like loving Vegas.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Do you think you could be like one of those like,
whoa.
You know,
I'm telling you what was a woman who,
um,
it was the,
uh,
Rita Rudner.
Does she still have a thing there?
I know she was always like,
kind of like,
you know,
she was a headliner and national headlines,
but when she settled down in Vegas and like,
like only did a show at this one place,
that's when I think she started making crazy man.
I'm loving the crowds,
the riff so that we could do it.
I've done two weekends already and it's been great to do one weekend out of the
month.
I do one weekend a month.
It's me headlining.
It's,
they're starting their marketing as Amy Schumer slaughterhouse and it's me,
Jackie Monaghan and then one other female comic like Nikki Glaser,
Rachel Feinstein or,
that's fucking awesome.
Yeah,
it's a fun show.
It's like the,
it's like this old timey theater.
Um,
the starlight in the of every single weekend marked off like what if something
comes up?
But what if they've been cool about I'm filming a special,
they were like,
no problem.
Just change it.
Yeah.
That's great.
I love it.
I'm loving it.
So it's once a month.
Is it like the last weekend of every month or something?
Like it's kind of all over the map so people can follow us on Twitter.
[inaudible] on Twitter or it'll be on my site.
On your Twitter page.
Twitter page.
Just for that show.
Not yet,
but there will be.
She'll be right.
It's like a new,
like it went really well the first two weekends cause right now I'm splitting it
with dice.
Oh,
he's there to do the podcast.
I've got to get,
get a hold of him.
He's there when I'm not there and maybe like I think and Gilbert Godfried
yet.
But it's,
it's been cool.
I'm digging the shit out of Vegas.
Wow.
That's crazy.
You're going to be a Vegas girl.
What do you dig about Vegas?
The hookers.
The math.
I don't like big crowds are like people drinking for the first time.
Um,
but uh,
like I really like the Sunday show.
I've,
I've been there a couple of days during the week now in Vegas is very cool.
Not on the weekends.
Yeah.
Everyone is like very chill and they're like,
okay,
now we have our world back.
Ah,
yeah.
It's a totally different vibe.
It's really,
it's like nice to crazy God damn city,
crazy goddamn city to have a city where everything stays open 24 hours a day.
Strip clubs,
food,
booze,
cabs.
Keep moving,
stay up.
You need coke.
I got called everything.
Boom,
boom.
And then even know I needed that.
Yeah.
You didn't even know you need until you got it right.
We're a tranny.
Norton can move there.
No,
I uh,
but it's like every night,
all the girls,
like,
they're all like,
these young girls squeezed into these tube dresses and the Kiehl's are so crazy.
They're just walking like,
ah,
they look so comfortable.
Yeah.
They don't even know what they want.
They don't know yet.
Putting their ass in a catapult right in their legs.
And just launching the crowd but launching it at the end.
But there no way to do it.
It's like everybody's splitting.
Like there's 10 girls in a hotel room.
Yeah,
there's always that.
The dudes are all just like so psyched wearing.
They're just,
they're just like,
fuck yeah.
Men with perfume on and shit.
What are you thinking about Cologne?
What do you think about when you're about to make out with a guy and you smell
some artificial smell on him?
I like a guys smell normal smell,
but I don't mind some old spice old spice.
Yeah,
but I don't know.
I don't know.
Daddy,
how many dudes do you think bought 50 cents?
Cologne?
I still wear Cologne.
Joe.
I know you're against Jeb.
I wear Cologne was spoil.
If I was you,
I'd probably be into it.
What does that mean?
These whatever help he gets?
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
I spray axe on my balls at the spray.
Little low on the board,
on my,
uh,
Bonnie.
Zach's when you spray on the balls,
does it sting?
No,
I have no open sores.
Like you
safe.
I did not shave my body,
my balls,
and then put aftershave on my balls just to see what it would feel like.
Kind of go,
whoa.
Um,
it was not,
I'll tell you it didn't really,
it hurt,
but it was more like,
I would say more like a really alert sensation that a pain reminded you.
Follicle.
It was like there was no cuts.
Luckily I didn't,
uh,
I didn't injure my balls during the shaving.
No,
there was no nicking.
I fortunately had a really good razor.
Yeah.
The event is,
I like to see my balls
to be covered and now my,
my balls are so salt and pepper.
It's so sad.
It's literally maybe 20%.
No,
not 20,
but 10.
I'd say $110 chocolate munchkins.
So one and a 10 is gray.
Mike.
They're going,
oh no.
And so I don't like looking at him.
So I shaved the board.
There's no one's in the,
no one's in the gray.
Pubes not girls drive
English.
I saw a dude at Runyon yesterday and he had facial hair from here down thick.
Like,
he looked like a wolf and he was walking with all these like overweight Hispanic
checks,
uh,
and like yelling at them.
So I caught up to one of them in the front and I was like,
is that your teacher?
And she's like,
yeah.
And I was like,
what's this?
What's it?
His hair?
And she's like,
his wife likes it like that.
And I was like,
oh my God.
Wow.
Paul's got a really hairy pussy.
And they lock up like velcro.
God,
I could.
That's how she makes sure she keeps eating.
Eat that Boosie I want to let your mom go out of my,
my mouth.
You
stop.
You'll go.
Well,
I'm thinking here we box.
You've got to go with you to that are Lebanese.
I don't know how to do a Lebanese accent will give it a shot.
I don't think
I'd be careful
making me sad.
You're a racist.
We're trying to like promote like unity and here,
you know how we were talking
podcasts the other day about these giant packs of wolves and the Soviet Union.
Somebody sent me a tweet right afterwards about a story where these 400 wolves
had killed 30 horses.
They're a pack of 400 wolves apparently is like from over a year ago,
but he just tweeted me to show me how bad it actually got.
There were pictures,
oh,
I don't know.
They didn't have pictures.
They had just had the article about how they're hiring teams of hunters to go
after these walls.
This is an unprecedented size pack.
They usually,
they go and pack of packs of like less than a dozen,
much smaller packs.
Really taking over taking the Thrones in the Soviet Union.
There's some spots were former Soviet Union,
what do you call it now?
Russia.
What do you call that?
Big,
what do you call it?
That because Russia is only part of it,
right?
Whatever it is.
It's like,
I think this is happening like up north and it's,
you know,
these poor people live in this
fucking sucks.
It sucks to live up there and apparently the wolves are starving so they just,
they just got together and I said,
listen,
the all of us together there,
I guess they figured it out.
It's overpopulated.
Six people,
six walls can't really go in and kill horses.
They'll shoot Ya.
But if there's 400 of us,
we're going to get some horses and they're not even going to shoot at you
because you're going to be terrified.
She imagined I just rush in and in,
in the Russian Tundra,
wherever the fuck it would be like frozen outside and you look out and see 400
wolves
horses.
Oh my God.
Well that was the thing about that game of Thrones movies.
Like it really connected you with how these people had to live back then.
It was a real like chicken,
it's my white walkers.
I was like,
I was watching it with Mrs Rogan and I was like,
what happens if one of those stupid wooden wheels brakes,
they have an extra wouldn't wheel.
We're going to camp here.
I was
looking at how slow it was moving to and then like that's real shit.
It moves like the way you jog.
That's how people got across the country.
We're talking about,
we've been traveling for over a month.
Look what you have to bring enough food and water for a month and this stupid
big box that they're pulling on dumb wooden wheels and they're just hoping
there's going to be a road there when they get there.
I was mad that the valet valet like wasn't ready with my car.
Yup.
Back then.
What did you have?
You had like a kingdom and then you had some roads that would go off until like
villages and shit and everything would just be the same ground that was stepped
on over and over again until it flattened out.
You know?
It's like from people walking.
That's how roads are creating,
right?
There weren't,
we're doing community service.
Keep the trail.
Chris Brown wasn't out there picking up passing cops.
Oh yeah.
Just in case you guys like ever have to do some hoeing wireless.
Yeah,
just like this.
That's not how I do it.
What's the difference?
What's really fucked up about that is that that's not that long ago.
I know.
Not that long ago.
That's how people live.
They just walked around and got on horses and couldn't go very far and people
are still doing it and then you'd have to worry about the people from,
you know over there getting all their shit together and coming over here and
fucking everybody up.
You always had to worry about that.
People are always looking to take everybody's shit.
Yeah.
It was like,
can you please just promise not to take our shit?
Like we promise we will not fuck with you.
Yeah.
When people,
the king would get there and they'd all get off their horses.
You just said,
I had to hope that the king wasn't a fucking total psychopath.
Like,
oh this new king,
he eats babies.
She's going to be a tough hundred year rob.
That was it.
James can do whatever the fuck they want.
That's what was really crazy.
Oh God.
Back in the day.
That's,
that's how people,
that's how people live
and like groups of people are supposed to die out like,
like species.
Like,
there's all,
you know,
the crazy like deep into Africa who still,
they're just like,
do not give a fuck what we're doing.
And they make like clay bowls and no one buys them anymore.
But like we like outsourced to help them and uh,
but now we've gotten so smart with medicine and the Internet that we're just
staying alive forever and we're like,
Fuck God,
whoa.
That was deep yo dude,
who has a BA in theater
down to the universe.
That should have been the opening to the new soul train.
That's it.
Do you think if you were king you would just go around the village and like pick
a different girl at like almost every day and let them do it more?
Would you like to find one girl that you really liked
martial artists and to have discipline and I would know that if I did that I
would go mad.
Yeah.
Brian
go barbarian style.
I don't like my,
that part of my brain.
I like to keep that part of my brain under route.
Just no,
just to experience different flavors.
Like a total neanderthal lurking that I got a wild,
yeah.
Pansy deep in the back of my brain.
And if I'm in a hotel and it's on fire,
that's when it comes out.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
No,
I'm saying if there's a bunch of people in front of a door,
we were at,
we were at a hotel fire in San Francisco.
It's four 30 in the morning and all these people were moving slow down this
flight of stairs.
And uh,
I was seriously contemplating running over some fucking pages,
started stabbings.
Cause I was like,
you guys are not the first of a lot of people were on Ambien.
Actually talk about this in my act.
Cause it's true where people want people,
a woman was having to explain to her husband as he was walking down the stairs.
Yeah.
What the fuck was going?
It was,
it
was,
it was crazy.
And I was like,
fuck,
that happened to me.
One second.
I'm going to me.
I was woken up.
I got woken up fire in the middle of the night at the hotel.
I was on Ambien.
And,
uh,
I walked to Mcdonald's with Abraham Lincoln.
We knew where,
where was this?
It was warm out.
Maybe Florida.
Wow.
You got woken up from a fire in your hotel to how many times does that happen to
you?
I wish I could wait once.
I mean once with me.
Yeah.
It was like,
yeah,
everybody was outside.
They were talking,
but I was like on drugs.
You know?
Brian was there.
It was a,
was Joe Diaz?
Ari was already too?
No,
I think it was just,
whoa.
No,
no.
Sorry.
I fell hard.
Was there too?
I know Jody,
I suppose he was Dunkin.
No,
it wasn't done.
It wasn't dark yet either way.
It was definitely Joey and Brian and I think Aria,
I think it was all right.
And we were,
we were all outside.
We're like,
this is crazy,
man.
They were waking up on the stairs like people were walking out of a blackout,
like the guys walking down the stairs,
like what?
What is happening?
And the woman's like,
we worked though.
The hotel's on fire.
I woke you up.
I was like,
grab the rails.
What's going on?
He kept,
they had this look on his face like he didn't,
he really didn't know how he got to that spot.
And you look beyond that spot.
Yeah.
People have like crazy stories about being in the car on the highway and waking
up and realize like,
Holy Shit,
what the fuck?
They don't even know how they got there.
They're just driving and it's totally legal data
talk to,
we give it out like,
like nothing.
And I know a bunch of people addicted to it.
Yeah.
I know several people addicted.
It's not good.
I was addicted to it.
Yeah,
I know.
It got it takes two to full amp.
Yes.
Take Xanax.
Like that's not good for you.
No,
it's not real.
It's not actual asleep.
He's a very functional guy.
Like a coma.
He's a civilian.
He's a hardworking businessman.
Yeah.
But uh,
he um,
he,
he fucking,
here's a stressful job and he can't go to sleep.
Just sometimes it takes to know what he's,
he runs a business.
It was very,
very complicated business and he's a long hours.
It takes work home with them and he can't sleep,
so he pops.
Ambiance do.
Yeah.
Well I think some people are just wrecked and they have so much shit going on
and they just need to shut it down.
Well,
a lot of people had to like really readjust in this fucked up economy too.
Yeah.
There's all,
I mean if you go and look at like real estate,
uh,
websites and like,
I like to look at houses just fascinated by like,
you know,
what's going on inside?
Like the construction of houses where it what?
Wow.
That'd be cool to live there.
What does it like to live and you know,
over by the ocean,
right?
What are those houses look like inside?
Um,
it's amazing how many houses on these real estate sites are all foreclosures,
foreclosure,
foreclosure short.
Some people lost their money.
They couldn't pay for the house anymore.
Losing their house.
They lose their house.
They have to move out and the bank owns it and they get nothing.
Bank sells it.
No,
they don't get shit.
You get,
you get,
you get out on your ass or you could have been paying for that house for 20
years.
It doesn't matter.
It's not yours anymore.
I do miss a years worth of payments and now they're going take it from you and
living in reneged on your loans are always rented.
And I don't have a car.
Like I don't want the economy.
I have not,
I know people are fucked,
but I've never had any money.
So it's never,
never really.
Yeah,
but it seems like really shitty.
Like if you have a family and you're just like,
what do you do?
They said 40% of young adults between 18 and 34 living home,
man,
I would almost want to go back.
Is that right?
Or are they really need is like nothing.
Like if my mom lived here,
I could almost live with my mom because I'm never really home serious.
No,
no,
I'm not.
I'm never home.
But,
uh,
if she like,
cause I use it just for sleeping and then I'll tell you what,
there's nothing wrong with living with your mom.
If your mom respects you as an adult and you love her and she's not a needy
person and you can be around her and you know,
you don't have to babysit or anyway like that.
Yeah.
My mom was a very easy going person.
If my mother wanted to move in,
I mean it would be no problem.
I mean,
I think we all have to kind of take care of her mom,
but at some point don't,
we're taking care of my mom.
My mom took care of my mom.
My mom could live with me.
Yeah.
So I think we're not going to have to do it.
She's not like tell you what to do.
Watch over your business mom.
Like some people have moms that are like really like invasive start problems are
alive.
I have friends whose,
who literally can't talk to their moms because their moms,
we'll start drama in their lives.
Yeah.
And start picking them.
The girlfriend or picking on the,
yeah.
Yeah.
And they don't know how to break that habit.
They've been doing it their whole lives.
But then you get old enough and you realize that,
that that behavior's insane.
Yeah.
You form patterns in your head based on certain ways of behaving that you've
always followed in these grooves in the past and they can be totally shitty
grooves.
I personally,
when I was younger,
had a bunch of Shitty grooves that I had to get my own mind out of.
Yeah.
I had a bunch of like jealousy grooves,
hater grooves,
feeling sorry for myself.
Grooves like a self defeating thoughts,
grooves.
Totally normal.
And as long as you're interested in,
you know,
making yourself better than
right.
But you've got to recognize them and dump them in.
That's what it is.
And some people don't.
And so they find themselves an old lady,
you know,
picking on their kids,
you know?
Yeah.
I've seen it.
It's gross.
Gross.
It's,
it's so awful.
And just like trying to make them need you,
like those mothers that light when their kids are sick.
Oh my mom is like pretty,
she's pretty cool.
But definitely there were some bad patterns,
but I can't even like really stay overnight in the same place as her.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just,
um,
it just gets too intense.
Uh,
yeah.
Just with like,
like what kinds of neediness?
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
Like I need a ton of alone time.
Like,
cause I'm so used to being by myself,
so it,
it'll be like,
mom,
I need to like,
just do this.
Like I need to write this thing.
And she'll be like,
okay,
that's fine.
And then she'll come over and she'll like put a chair in front of me and read a
book,
like in my direction and I'm like,
yeah,
that's crazy.
Like,
you know that,
that's insane.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Some people
don't get that.
No.
Everybody's got their own needs when it comes to the time and space alone.
Ah,
I don't know how I would ever,
I don't know how I would,
I'm going to like ever live with somebody again.
You can live with someone.
You just have to make sure that you have your respected to that space.
It would make you have to live in a place where you can,
you know,
have a little room away from them.
You pitching like you'd just shut a door somewhere.
Yes,
I mean like are you in 10 so you're like throwing items around the house or
anything like that or,
no,
I didn't know.
I'm like,
I want to be as drama free as possible.
I'm not,
I'm not needy.
I'm like,
how many domestic violence calls have you made in a wall,
you know,
domestic violence,
whole silence holes is that you were saying glory holes,
Brian in a whole like a plaster zero.
How many have I caused?
Probably a lot.
So you've seen him before.
So there,
there's definitely some number of walls next to my head punched.
Yeah.
Wow.
Really?
You deserve,
hold on.
Stop yelling.
You deserved it.
Psycho you cause you're going through a breakup,
right?
No,
no,
just don't take it out on me
guy.
When I was,
um,
in my early twenties,
like when I was 19 to 21 that uh,
he didn't hit me,
but I got hurt by accident all the time.
Yeah.
We had one night where he,
we were like 21,
like drinking a lot,
like drinking martinis before we would go out and it was like we were in love
with each other.
And so scared of losing each other and it was fucking wild and horrible.
And One night he,
um,
we were out at a bar and I was like trying to make him jealous.
I was like dancing with another guy.
Uh,
I'm 19,
I'm wearing like a tube top.
I'm like,
life is amazing.
And he comes over and yells at me and I spit on him.
Uh,
yeah.
And I,
so I spit on him and he like grabs me and throws me out of the bar and chases me
all over.
Wound up like throwing me on the roof of a car.
I ran into an apartment,
uh,
like just ran in like for help cause he was chasing me and these guys,
it was like,
they were obviously doing a bunch of illegal stuff like these,
I think it was like some sort of a gang and uh,
they were like,
okay,
just,
they hit me and like their bathroom and then he came there and was making a
scene.
So the guys threw me out because they didn't want the cops to come and he wound
up getting in a fist fight with them.
End of the night.
We're back at our apartment.
We lived together in Santa Barbara.
He starts breaking classes over his own head.
And then I finally find a way to run out of the apartment.
And he was chasing me with a knife,
like American psycho chasing me around our apartment complex.
And I bang,
Bang,
Bang on the door.
Finally someone opened and I go in this apartment and it was a guy,
um,
who's chopping up a woman.
Like,
I'm not kidding.
He,
I'd like seen this guy around our apartment.
I walk in,
he closes the door,
I noticed it smells like shit,
like feces.
And I look over,
his wife is in a hospital,
she has no arms and legs and her mouth is cocked open.
I'm not like,
this is all totally true.
I've never like told this.
I haven't thought about this in years.
But uh,
and they call and I was like,
then I was more scared in that house.
But they called,
they called the cops for me and uh,
and yeah,
and I got out and moved back to New York.
Did you ever talk to that guy again?
Yeah,
we're back together and I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
We were,
we were kids.
We were horrible kids get a knife.
He was chasing me.
I don't,
I don't know.
He was,
he was drunk and he was really afraid of losing me.
Uh,
I,
I don't know what his plans were,
but uh,
yeah,
we,
we like I'm just gonna give you a second gash.
You wanted a new hole.
Um,
but it was like after him,
dating was weird because I was like confused by if a guy really liked me or not.
Like I dated this really nice guy after him and I was just like,
I was like,
are you into this?
And he's like,
yeah,
I'm told why.
I was like,
cause you've never like spit on me or threatened my coworkers.
Like are you,
is there any passion here?
He's like a,
what do you want from me?
But yeah.
So the way I feel about it,
that's all real.
Yeah.
Oh is your real feeling like that?
Like when a guy doesn't do anything crazy or violent that he's not really you?
No,
that was just me at 22,
like being really fucked up by this relationship.
So that's why when someone's like really did feel that.
Yeah,
I felt,
I really felt believed that because they weren't spitting on your warrant,
violent towards your core.
That whole next year I was confused.
I didn't think that the guy I was dating really cared about me because of that.
And the guy was dating.
I mean he really liked did a number on me.
Um,
he would like rip the shower curtain down when I was in there and do a number
two,
he would rip the shower,
I'd be like in the shower and he would like come in and rip it down and like,
like point at me and laugh.
Um,
like just crazy horrible shit.
And I thought,
I thought we were living with a crazy person.
I know it was really bad and it was like,
but I was in love with him,
so it's like,
no,
I've done that.
Yeah.
He had a cock on him.
Wow.
Yeah,
probably I was 20 and he was,
he just knew how to make it happen.
I don't know what it was.
It was,
it was 10 years ago.
No,
no,
there was no shitting and farting.
Brian.
I mean,
but I understand when people like,
I really don't judge anybody who gets in some awful relationship cause I've
always been like a strong,
like I don't keep my mouth shut.
Chicks.
So I think like you,
like it could happen to anybody.
Like you can be,
you can fall in love with somebody who hurts you.
Well,
especially when you're 20 years old,
you really,
you're a child,
you don't know anything.
Right.
But I've never been in a relationship with any sort of even meanness.
I,
I've never since then,
I don't think I've even said anything to anyone in a relationship that I regret.
Awesome.
Yeah,
I've learned chase of a knife.
It was,
it was really bad and he was really sick.
I would feel
like he would like grab me and then I'd have a huge bruise and the next day I'd
be like,
oh,
he's going to feel so bad about this.
Like I would feel bad for him.
Right.
You know,
never again.
That guy's my holocaust.
He didn't feel bad when he grabbed you when you left bruises.
He would like,
can you really convince me that it was my fault?
It was really like,
wow.
Yeah,
it was.
I was a kid.
How old was he?
My Age.
Wow.
Yeah,
he had a good PillCam.
Are you one of those girls?
I bruise easy.
Have you ever met one of those girls were like,
like you could just pretty much like touch her and then the next day like you
could just go like this.
Is that what you tell yourself Brian?
You sound like maybe like maybe you're a contender.
No,
no,
no.
I've actually dated somebody that like serious,
like she could just go like,
like let's just put her hand down too hard on a desk and she would get a bruise
right here.
Fine.
I get massages a lot and I know that's super unhealthy.
I mean,
she's like,
it is some sort of of iron deficiency.
You should drink more water and you should stop shaking her.
No more math.
No math,
no more math.
Yeah.
I feel that our relationship with somebody where you guys brought out the
fucking worst in each other.
Oh yeah.
Just toxic.
Oh,
sure.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
I've had those.
Yeah.
Especially when you're young and you don't realize like what fighting in a
relationship is.
Yeah.
You don't know what it is supposed to be yet.
And you,
you know,
you say shitty things to each other and you didn't realize like,
oh,
what the fuck am I doing?
Take that shit back.
I took me once to learn all of that stuff.
I got every lesson in one dude.
Right?
Yeah.
I got lucky that I never had anybody that crazy,
but it's fascinating to watch people,
you know when you,
you get close to somebody,
you don't know him very well,
and then all of a sudden within like a month or two months,
you're hanging out with him every day and you're like deepen their life.
Like when you remember when you're young and you first start meeting people,
I mean,
that's essentially what happens,
right?
You're like,
throw yourself at point.
You're like so codependent.
You don't even know.
You don't know how to regulate it,
right?
Like us.
And then you get into there with wife and you go,
Whoa,
I'm dealing with fucking Hornets nest here.
Like,
yeah.
What is all this craziness you got going on here?
Yeah.
Not No more now.
Like I,
I met a dude recently and I was like,
you could try and get him to the music.
Brian.
Oh,
you got some sexy piano player.
You met,
met a dude.
I met a guy was the guy do,
um,
I don't mind comedian.
He's a nine comedians.
He fancies himself to be funny.
Everybody does who?
That's all good.
No,
no,
no.
But she too,
but right away.
Really?
Okay,
Brian,
you're fired,
Brian.
You are really not bringing it to that.
You're in a bad place.
I'm not going to hold it against you.
I support you.
There's a person isn't a fucking sound manager country.
Then we're fucked it up.
Like you just got this equipment today and he's just pressing it thinks it's
cute.
What does this do?
He's just pushing that retard angle.
Hard and strong.
So the guy is non-successful non comedian.
Yeah.
But what I'm saying is that probably not whoa,
like he will.
Yeah.
Like everybody wants to be doing better than they're doing,
but it's just like a general,
I want to be doing better.
Do you think he can be your creepy manager that steals money from you?
No,
I don't think he's got the intellect.
No.
That's what I'm searching for.
You searching for a [inaudible] guys,
guys,
that's going to just take me for everything.
No,
I was just going to come along and be your manager.
Everything.
I need my bills behind your back and that is that what happens?
Girls date guys,
they become their managers.
Why not?
No,
I just,
what I'm saying is at 30 like meeting a guy now you just like,
see,
you're like a,
you're like,
oh,
oh no,
no,
no.
Like I,
and I'm not even going to fuck you.
Like I'm not,
let's just stop this right here,
but the strike one,
right?
Yeah.
I was in a party the other night and there was a dude who just just have these
like Uber Douche vibes.
Yeah.
For no reason.
Like,
you know,
you just look at a guy and you go,
wait,
what are you the worse?
What's going on here?
He goes,
a bunch of people I didn't know,
but uh,
he had a thumb ring.
That's all it take for me.
Well,
I have a wallet chain.
I'm really glass houses.
I'm throwing rocks.
I don't think a wall chains.
I bet it's nothing.
It's no fun.
It's pretty had a submarine and he was wearing leather flip flops and a pony
tail.
And when he talks,
he was my manager
over exaggerate like the of the,
the name of a country that's in Mozambique.
Uh,
I just really like on a sec.
Then I found out that he was living off the alimony from a rich woman that he
had married.
Yeah,
you're like,
it all adds up.
It all adds up.
Well this is hilarious.
It's amazing when you just see a guy's like a,
like a male hustlers type character.
And I saw him,
I observed him,
I watched him,
I followed him around because I was fascinated by him cause he was fabulous.
He went over to these mothers.
And,
uh,
although all these mothers were hanging around and,
you know,
he's fairly decent looking guy and uh,
it just goes over and tries to talk really seriously.
This is a wow,
what a beautiful ensemble.
What,
uh,
an amazing bouquet of flowers and sensitively put,
they're just so beautiful.
So many.
Yeah.
Oh,
well not this chick.
A guy that was collecting alimony from a woman is not a man,
not a man.
And women should be doing it either.
It seems awful.
Uh,
well,
you know what?
I disagree.
If a man is taken care of a woman and she has kids,
or if you told her she doesn't have to work,
I'm rich,
come with me.
And then she's like,
do you ever send money to get her shit back together again?
I think everybody deserves,
you know,
I don't think anybody deserves to,
to be fucked up and on skid row or what have you.
If there's a way to avoid it where the other person could just be a decent and
moral person.
Right.
Breakups are so bad for the most part.
A lot of times people don't want to help.
The other person and want them to be a fucking homeless person.
They need the courts to kind of step in.
Yeah.
But that dude,
but like that dude at the party,
like I've had guys that like that do well.
You know some guys that are a little bit famous and you see how they're,
their shit would work on somebody else.
Like,
oh yeah,
girls like when you pay attention,
you,
when you ask them questions and see something about
them,
they're like,
cause we can just project everything we've ever wanted on to the dude.
So,
but that,
but like that whole game,
like I wish that worked on me.
He see it coming right
a mile away.
No,
you don't.
You imagine no baffle.
You'd be every day,
especially out here.
But the,
the,
the male hustler approach talking about cleanses.
Who when he just returned from a detox cleanse,
I was like,
this guy isn't a goddamn movie.
This is,
this is like a Judd Apatow movie.
And this guy is like the,
the new age,
you know,
it's like Russell brand and like some,
no,
not even Russell brackets.
Brussel vans.
Always funny.
No.
But I mean like,
well,
why Douche bag?
Yeah.
But he plays a wild douche bag guys.
And even wild,
he's just a mile.
Does that guy like himself like,
or does he,
when he's alone in the bathroom,
does he look in the mirror and you have to keep himself from sobbing?
Yeah,
I hope so.
You can only hope that guy hates himself.
If,
if anyone ever assaulted him on the street who would just quit,
he would curl up in a ball.
It's just,
if you just had one thing to him,
he's,
if someone attacked him physically,
he would fall apart.
That's why like when those guys are in my audience.
So this guy became my science project for the party,
which I did.
I was,
I was thinking about,
I'll start twittering about it.
I tweeted about it while I was falling the sky.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
I watched him talk to a young boy and that's where it's shit got really
interesting because,
uh,
no,
not,
not like that.
Like the kid was,
I should say a teenager.
The kid was about it probably like 18 watch for 20 minutes.
And,
uh,
they were talking about things and you know,
the,
the guy was doing his sort of smoldering thing with them and you know,
being wise and,
and uh,
the kid asked him,
what do you do?
Okay.
And he didn't answer.
He didn't answer.
It doesn't do anything.
He had like,
um,
like a little pause a,
and it was really crazy.
And then he,
the kid asked him again like he tried to like change the subject or he tried to
like add something yeah.
To the past statement that he,
you know,
the,
the previous sentence on the right to finish it as if the guy didn't ask him
what he do.
And then the kid asked again,
what do you do?
And then he had this sort of a stutter and we're working in developing property.
Right.
No,
you know,
I don't know what it is,
what the truth is.
He's like,
I am journaling and going to whole foods twice a day.
Well it was a,
it was a fascinating dude because he was doing it again.
He had gotten one rich woman to marry him and then he was there at the party
with an older rich woman.
Ah,
that's fascinating.
Yeah.
Setting a woman.
Fascinating.
People are so sad.
Well it's,
you know,
people need things in some,
some women don't need a us,
a guy who some wild motherfucker was going to run away.
You need some bitch ass.
It needs you to pay the bills and pretending.
Yeah.
Well there was like that,
this whole article in the Atlantic magazine about how we used to think of it
being like part of the black culture that um,
that it would be like the dudes were either playboys,
like if they're successful,
like they can have lots of chicks or a deadbeat.
Like you would have to kind of,
as a woman who is successful,
you have to like take on a deadbeat or cheese and it should,
it's not,
but it's not anymore.
That's totally everybody.
It's not just for one community.
Like that's how it is now.
Yeah.
With,
uh,
with dudes because women are succeeding more and more and guys like there's like
that plateau.
Well,
there's certainly positions where the roles are reversed,
where the woman's taken care of the man,
especially older women and younger,
better looking,
man,
that shit's like super common.
Yeah.
As long as a woman,
it's like just like men and the young girls that are like a little bit lost and
they take care of them and that,
you know,
they're older men with a lot of money that that shit's going on.
Especially in this economy.
There's,
there's guys that are putting their ass up in the air.
Oh my God.
The branded over hook me up.
I can get you hooked up if you ever been to that website.
Legs.
Howard stern always talks about cougar life Europe,
been to that website.
It's a website with cougars.
I just want to get down and fuck.
And so you get all these girls that have been taken care of that just got out of
a divorce.
Now they're super rich.
It's kind of interesting.
I find it hard to believe that those hot ones need a fucking website.
I think those girls are getting Dick hurled at them everywhere they go.
I just,
yeah,
I hard.
I find it hard to believe that if they don't have friends,
it's this summer.
What's the idea?
What the site,
is it like it's like a go to dinner or is it like just come over and fuck.
Let's go out and eat how it is awesome drinks.
They know bill in the house.
30 or 40 days of moisture.
I know want to use every day packs in fleet.
Rest the life.
No permanent state of hibernation,
and they gotta sneak lube in there,
which is always embarrassing,
you know,
to imagine actually brought the bone.
The girls.
Got It.
Okay.
Sneaks.
Looms sneak some lube in there.
I'll be right back.
I'm going to go to the bathroom.
She goes to the bathroom and sneak some blue in their boxes.
Done the boxes.
Docs is done online.
It's a sandbag.
You're fucking a sandbag,
right?
The Mojave.
You're fucking two slabs of beef jerky.
That is so make them to about a beef jerky.
Talking about my future right now.
All Callisto you're,
you're hands and cows can you inside of your vagina if you are like a hooker.
I just insisted on fucking all day,
every day.
He really had a lot of money that you owed and you tag them all.
Come on next.
Next.
Which is it possible to get a callus and you're posting?
Okay.
Yeah.
It's like skinning your knee.
Yeah,
maybe.
I bet it would have to.
If you let it heal a little bit,
it would probably countless.
Wow.
But who has time?
That's rough.
Who has the time?
What do you think is the number the woman was fuck the most dudes ever.
What did they do that work at once?
Yeah.
No,
in her life.
Oh Gosh.
Different dudes.
It's gotta be a lot.
We had a male porn star in a podcast recently and it was like,
how much?
How many people did you fuck last,
uh,
last year?
And he was just like,
I don't know a lot.
I'm like,
would you say over 200?
He's like probably weighs over 300.
And I'm like,
what?
Well,
he's singing about it.
If he's a porn star,
he's probably working how many days a week?
Probably like four or five.
Four or five days a week.
And how many different girls you think you fucked?
I don't know.
It usually like a lot of these movies you're doing like the whole movie,
like one sitting
like four different scenes for different group one day.
Yeah.
Usually you have to that one day.
Oh he probably,
I don't think they come alive,
but that's why the end.
That's the most disappointing thing when you watched a porn and the guy's like,
oh,
that's what I'm trying to shake it.
He chitty bang and the girl's like getting her spit bubbles on it to make it
seem to me like as if it's bigger.
I see what's going on there.
That's nothing very small.
An unimpressive load,
sir.
I don't know about other girls,
but for me the size of the load is,
does not matter doesn't it?
You'd like all of it.
Oh,
wouldn't you be more excited if we got came like a whole shit load.
Like wow,
he's so excited.
Like it was.
It all is.
And then instead of a guy like this,
then yeah,
I guess it's pretty good.
I'll just drop a load here.
Doesn't seem very enthusiastic.
Not very complementary.
I wouldn't,
I don't think I would take it personally.
That excited about to cut you off for a week and see if we could pick up the
volume soldier.
Some girls were into that though.
Yeah.
Some girls like big loads.
They find that Brian.
Uh,
yeah.
I think that don't like the thick ones.
You know,
once in a while when you don't have a lot of water.
You've been drinking a lot.
It's so unhealthy dude.
Really Thick Yogurt.
Yeah,
like it's like almost like lumpy,
like mashed potato or cottage cheesy or something like that.
Frozen yogurt loads.
I love that.
It's like great.
It's funny that some girls actually do like loads.
They like the swallow.
Some girls love it.
It's like their favorite thing.
Loads of their mouth.
Yeah.
The summer you've had a few coronas,
you could use the salt.
Is it good for your skin?
Is that I look so young,
Joe.
That's why you guys say that.
Yeah,
I would think so.
Probably do just as good a job.
Is that shit real boy?
Yeah.
That's a legit,
is it still around?
Isn't that like supposed to keep women a young forever.
I've got something better that you should try.
We'll talk.
I don't think so.
Do you guys remember the Solo Flex woman?
There was like a 50 year old.
Do you remember that pitch was hot and she was like 50 and she's on cougar life
now.
You think she's still rocking it when you're 50 and like 2003 that's a long time
ago man.
Back then you were hot,
but the wall is near.
Not much you can do about that.
You know God aging as a woman just seems like so often it's a mother fucker for
everybody and that's going to,
how old are you?
30 there's no getting around it either.
Five more years.
So you hit the wall.
You think exercise is the only thing so nice.
You can hold it off a little bit.
If you stay in shape,
hold it off a little bit.
Run.
I think that keeps people young.
Sure.
Yeah.
But your knees are going to get jacked.
You run on the concrete.
Are you running on?
No,
I run either on the treadmill or a dirt.
Well,
that's thing.
Yeah.
I use my stuff.
I roll on just to sleep in our children.
Run on your toes,
you know they say like those toe shoes.
That's really the way to run.
Yeah,
but then I'll be a douche bag.
Do you have those shoes?
I have them,
yeah.
That's hilarious.
I don't wear 'em except to work out.
I wasn't going to work out.
I,
I'm going to kick the back.
Sometimes if it's cold outside really are like little piglet,
but Jim is in my garage and sometimes it's like if it's 40 degrees out,
I'm working out at 40 degrees.
It's hard to kick a leather bag with serious fitness.
Dude.
When I see people like running,
I see people running around central park in those footies and I'm just right
now.
Is it helping you that much?
What it is is the,
the way people run is an unnatural way.
The way people run where you go heal and then down to your toes.
Yeah.
That's not how you run.
If you were running out barefoot in the world,
right,
you were,
you would run and you would use the natural design of your foot as a shock
absorber.
And that's what people do instead of drop down on your heel because you have a
big pad there.
Yeah.
Because a shoe company has put an artificial pad in the back of your heel.
They,
they literally changed the way people run.
Yeah.
But don't we offer that before that people would have to run and do.
The natural way to do is to land on the ball of your foot and you,
if you look at the design of the foot,
your foot bends and gives you land on the toe and the ball of the foot and then
it gives and what these shoes and any,
any barefoot like exercise program.
I lift weights barefoot and a I'll do,
um,
a lot of different things,
different exercises,
barefoot.
And the idea behind it is that that is that that's a natural way for your body
to carry stress and to move things around.
And that if you run on the ball of your foot like that,
it actually saves your body all the damage that a lot of people get from the
pounding of a of knees.
So that's why the tone wasn't the natural way.
Not Be on concrete though.
Yes,
you're absolutely right.
And that's just like a fucking concrete concretes,
bad period for anybody,
any way you run.
It's just,
it's hard.
It doesn't give nice dirt.
Like if you're on it like a nice dirt hill,
you know when you hit that thing,
it compacts a little compact.
So there's a nice dirt hill near a house that I used to run until there was
three fucking mountain lions signings in my neighborhood.
The routine now running this hill anymore.
But uh,
it was a nice steep dirt hill.
And you could feel it give as you ran into her in the sand.
No,
no.
Running in the sand is fantastic for you.
Yeah.
I mean,
you've got to build your body up.
I wouldn't recommend it to someone who's not shame.
Oh,
I loved running on the beach and then like barefoot.
But then I heard like who told you there's anything wrong with that?
Sand is great.
No,
I was going to say piece of advice.
I'm going to probably go get those shoes running.
The sand is hard.
It's hard to run.
I mean as long as you don't step on something.
But if you know,
if,
if you know,
if you step on something you're fuck broken bottles and shedding me if you trust
the beach.
But if you're a,
if you're running barefoot in the sand,
it's really good for you.
That's good.
Yeah.
So was running sand dunes.
That's fucking up incredibly good for you.
It's me.
Insane is,
I'm always in hotels of course.
And in hotel gyms when people just come in to just check it out,
don't you always see like couple of things they just like,
they'll come down like that.
It's like it,
that's a gym.
Like you can tell how,
how nice the hotel is.
You're going to know how nice the gym,
like what do you,
it's just,
I don't know why.
It just makes me so mad.
Why you don't like being looked at why you're a oils.
I love being.
Look
that what it is.
They just come in and they don't commit.
They don't send,
someone's going to flirt with me while we trained together.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's it.
You know?
That's what cool thing about these mirrors there in the corners.
You just look one way.
Then even know if you're looking at that
on the ceilings in here,
what are you laughing appropriately at like an episode of friends,
so he has to say,
what is so funny?
Oh my God,
I forgot how funny friends was.
Oh,
it was more of my favorite.
Shows
me the worst dating coach.
You'd be the worst
of all time.
Just creating scenarios are coming up with answers.
Dudes have questions.
You know Amy Schumer's at the gym,
how am I going to make this happen?
Yeah.
By laughing loudly at France.
Really,
really loud.
The girl would be the one who laughed really loudly and see.
You're upset that the people come in where they just look because they're not
going to play your game.
You feel like this is another person.
This is a new player,
has entered the game.
You know when you're at the gym and you're on your little lipstick go machine
and you listen to you Donna Summers music,
I'm picturing you with a purple iPod.
Nano,
the,
no,
not even a nano.
What's the one?
The clip on the clip while
legwarmers dude,
you have no shoes on because they haven't invented,
choose yet.
Get upset.
You look up and it's some people just looking at the gym,
you fuckers
all wrong at the gym.
You me all wrong.
If the gene is your mindset when you go to the chat and what is the,
what's the thought process?
I listened to Biggie and odd future and um,
am I listen a bad shit and I run like I'm angry.
You're angry.
And about when you're really pushing yourself.
Do you think about the ex boyfriend with a knife running through the apartment
complex?
Did you said cause that's what I think about you.
And then I stopped,
I paused the treadmill so I can come and then I get that and I just pushed
through.
She is orgasm without even knowing it.
Did you realize that a lot of women are admitting now that there was a study
done?
A lot of women are achieving orgasm during strenuous exercise.
What?
Yes.
Very common.
Yeah.
What are they
doing?
Let me know.
I'll,
I'll Google it here.
Study shows.
Just put this little balls in there and I was so sick in the hospital.
I haven't masturbated in like a week.
Really?
Yeah.
I like forgot about it.
That's how sick I was.
I haven't thought about masturbate with another guy.
Like a real stupid fuck.
Yeah.
Um,
I guess cause when you were together a long time,
women athletes for women have orgasms at the gym study shows.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's really true.
What are they doing at the gym?
Findings and their trainers findings add qualitative and quantitative data to a
field that has been largely unstudied I'll field.
Yes.
What,
what really makes the vaginal go pop pop,
pop.
That's my field,
my field.
I'm in the old gas of field of field as a,
as a,
as women's orgasms.
Been a field,
um,
largely unstudied according to researcher Debbie.
Oh,
Debbie,
you silly bitch.
Debbie.
Debbie always thinking about our club loves posting day.
Debbie probably has a flashlight and she's like licks it while she was sitting
close to me.
So awesome.
This is my field.
I'm doing research on my phone in the field.
You guys,
you can't talk.
Debbie,
you're awesome.
Thank you for your work.
Co Director of the Center for Sexual Health Promotion at Indiana University.
For instance,
Alfred Kinsey and his colleagues first reported the phenomenon in 1953 saying
about 5% of women they had interviewed mentioned orgasm linked to physical
exercise.
Wow,
that's fucking awesome.
For those five checks,
what is the spring?
The report of so called core orgasms named because of their seeming link.
Two exercises for core abdominal muscles have circulated in the media for years
according to the researchers.
So apparently it's working your core.
So the getting on the knees and tightening up the pussy.
That shit's real.
Yeah.
Well you want to do is you get on your knees.
Okay.
And I don't want you to rock your ass back to your heels.
Pull yourself up with your abs while you're squeezing your pussy.
Why don't I just rub my clit?
What like why all the while the work,
you do this while you're at work and no one even knows you do it while you're
performing some exercise and you get some good solid try it.
Right now it's a rockstar in the works of the women who had orgasms drain 45%
said the first experience was linked to abdominal exercises,
45% 19 due to biking and spinning nine point to full dance floor masters.
Robin likes to spin it.
Yeah,
I can see spinning 9.3 on a bicycle to climbing poles or ropes.
Oh,
my stomach is still out from all the saline solution.
7% reported a connection with weightlifting.
What does the sailing solution,
they had a pump in New York.
The pumps?
Yeah.
They put,
they pump five big ivy bags in and so like I'm,
I feel like okay now,
but I still have all the Waterweight.
Yeah.
Now when you were really sick,
did you try to drink water or was it dehydration from throwing up?
I tried by threw it up.
Wow.
I threw up on somebody giving me x rays in the hospital.
Yeah.
Whoa.
It was bad.
Wow.
It was really,
really bad.
What's,
so what did you call the place that gave you the a crab cake in Phoenix?
Um,
the,
well,
it was at my hotel,
but their insurance is paying whatever,
my insurance really,
so they've admitted that it's their fault,
two meals that day.
And they were both at my hotel.
Oh,
there's no question.
No.
If,
ands or buts.
Yeah.
Wow.
I was there working.
I'd done press all morning like they were,
I didn't drink or anything like that.
They're being cool about it.
Yeah.
Hey,
clams in Illinois and Man Tino Illinois and kind of a fucking horribly sick once
then that,
you know,
that night,
like five,
six hours later,
it just started.
It hit me.
The cramping was the worst.
Yeah.
You know,
like when you're trying even kicked in maybe an hour and a half after you ate
it.
Only an hour and a half.
Yeah.
Really?
Wow.
That's incredible.
That must be really bad.
It was,
you say it takes hours usually.
Sometimes it is,
but I,
I had the same thing happened to me like,
uh,
about two months ago.
Where you driving home?
I was like,
I'm gonna shit myself right now and I feel it's make puke out.
The bubbling inside of you.
Yeah,
it was bad.
It was,
it hit like a little,
like I'm an hour and a half,
two hours and then it really hit,
the worst one ever got me was from a mushroom pizza.
I was in Providence,
Rhode Island in a comedy club and I ordered a mushroom pizza.
One of those frozen pizzas.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That was the only thing I ate.
And Holy Shit,
the mushrooms especially,
it's very possible that in these places,
like they dehydrate things or rather a defrost things and then refreeze them.
Oh,
and that's really bad.
Really bad.
Yeah,
for sure.
And Pizza now.
Yeah,
sure.
You can.
I don't think,
I can't imagine ever,
I couldn't even say the word crab cake until today.
Why I threw up when I was a kid to some Jack Daniels,
I was like 14.
Oh,
the smiling first puking from booze.
Yeah.
I threw up in a cab.
I threw up,
I threw up on the streets.
Did you drink?
I don't remember.
It was a lot though.
Yeah.
While having sex.
Have I?
Yeah.
No.
If you having been with a girl that threw up,
we'll have them having,
having too close,
like we were about to get it on and then she started throwing up.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I've had that.
I had finished and her hair punch out,
took off month,
hold it down,
grab her hair and she tries to fight cause he wanted to have an orgasm.
You get a pin down the left arm with your Shin,
right arm,
you know,
horrible.
Holy Shit.
That's your move.
That's games of Thrones style.
That is,
that's the one thing you see by all the,
the,
the raping and pillaging going on back then.
It's the best.
That's really like you,
that's really how people live.
They just took whatever they wanted.
You really had to put out.
Yeah.
There wasn't a lot of arguing with barbarian.
There was no like,
Oh let's wait.
Let's wait a month.
It was like,
um,
get on your knees.
Do you find yourself not attractive to a man?
If he is a,
if it was like struggling or if he's like he doesn't have his shit together or
if he make less money than you.
Wow.
Oh my God.
I am like blue collar fever.
I,
I've dated anyone with money.
I like dudes like I liked the Marlon Brando Street car.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I like,
I will like,
I'm,
yeah,
I'm easy.
I want like a guy that's smart and um,
yeah,
who like knows how to fuck me.
Got a guy and he understands that your job is to be smart and nice and know how
to fuck me and then we can get married and then you guys could go on the road
together and he could just like what?
Read books and
no,
I don't,
I need a lot of alone time.
Oh,
well I didn't always going to be eating my pussy all that much.
Yeah.
He can come.
I'll be a Denver.
No,
I uh,
yeah.
What's your ideal guy?
I don't know.
I hope I have not met anybody like whoever he is yet.
But yeah,
I think I want like a simple ass like smart,
confident dude that's easily,
ah,
like a job would be nice.
But I don't have to have one for you.
Well like I want him to what?
He could be like something weird like a sculptor or something.
Like I don't need them to have like a great job.
Well listen,
there's a lot of sculptors in Vegas.
No,
I really don't want to do a sculptor.
That was a bad [inaudible] have to work on like get a job.
No,
I don't know.
I don't,
I would,
I really don't think I would ever date a guy in finance or something like that.
Like some of these suit wearing.
I don't think I would date an a guy that wore a suit to a thing.
I just like all those evil,
scary,
boring.
I can't relate
muscle.
We're normal guys.
One of my best friends is an accountant and he's,
he's,
he's fucking crazy,
crazy.
He's just stuck,
buttoned down all day.
But you know he loves like you when I talked to him on the phone and he's crazy.
He's,
he's,
he's a regular dude,
but he's just has a job and he's good at it.
So he gets paid well.
So that's what he does.
And the cats and dogs.
I like dogs,
hate cats
kind of questions.
You always bring something down to a six year old level,
writing out her profile for what's your favorite color?
Please tell me the truth.
I knew.
Do you know
or men are intimidated by the fact you're your comedian ever?
I would assume so.
I don't know.
They don't want to start talking shit.
They've seen you at roasts,
Mike Tyson.
You went head to head with Mike Tyson foods.
Don't want to talk shit with you.
What?
You're looking for?
Fireman from Hoboken.
Just like a Patrick Swayze type dude and a movie from the 1980s yeah.
Take your pants.
We're not trying to marry you off,
right.
We just,
we went down that road and we stuck with it for no reason.
Trying to get some entertainment.
Here's the podcast.
Supposed to make it funny and I'm like really telling Craig,
here's the podcast.
She goes on a date,
every episode's a different date that we hook you up to get her.
Yeah.
You got to trust mentored in one week.
You can't trust men to want to dudes are creepy.
It's a,
it'd be nice.
We could trust him.
Bootcamp people we know though or something.
Come on man.
How many dude?
You know,
I'm not going,
you guys aren't setting me up.
I really truly don't trust you guys.
Yeah,
exactly correct.
A lot of black friends.
It's fine.
I've never been with a black guy.
He's got a lot of black and lesbian friends,
so he's got mixed.
Whatever you need,
that's going to shock you.
Parents,
Asian girls,
boys and girls.
That's what I want.
So is this,
this,
this thing that happened
today that I don't totally,
completely understand,
but it's some,
uh,
new Obama,
a jobs act that he just signed in Matt.
He be wrote this blog about how fucking terrible it is.
What's the act?
I don't completely understand it.
But though the way it's been explained to me is that essentially almost
legalizes fraud.
The idea is that it used to be if you wanted to take a company public,
you had to file all sorts of paperwork and have a hiring an account and have all
these financial statements in place.
But now they say you don't need to hire an accountant before the company is
taking public,
nor do you need to do so for five years after the company goes public.
So it's almost like you can fucking lie about your financial statements for five
years without any independent accounting of your claims.
I don't totally completely understand it.
I'm reading,
Oh Matt Taibbi be getting money and lying.
And when public would things go Publix manipulating the stock market,
um,
I don't understand what,
what the,
the pros are of this,
this thing it might have,
see when,
when they sign sign an act is,
there's usually a lot,
yeah.
Shit in there.
It's not just one statement.
Right.
But people said it's out bill one thing and that's,
they put things in like this.
Yeah.
That
make it easier for certain businesses or make it easier for certain special
interest groups that,
you know,
it's like we'll give you this but you got to give us that.
So I don't know what the,
the,
the positive benefit of this job Zack is we've got to find a lot according to
um,
Matt Taibbi,
it's really crazy.
It's really strange.
He equates it and he says it's like formerly eliminating steroid testing for the
first five years of a baseball player's career.
You can pretty much bet you're going to see a lot of home runs and those first
few years after you institute a rule like that,
but you better be ready to stick a lot of asterisks in the record books 10 or 15
years down the line,
which is a great analogy to what if this is correct,
if you really don't have to have the proper accounting to,
to go for a company to go public for the first five years,
that's like,
this is craziness.
It's like they keep passing more and more laws and they keep doing more and more
things to control people and to make it,
to limit our ability to defend ourselves against the government.
And they keep doing more and more things that allow people to somehow or another
siphoned money out of the system.
And you gotta wonder where does this end when they stop making new bills and
start trying to fix this fucking ridiculous government we have.
Well,
the foreclosure
bill,
what we were just talking about with the fork,
the hell those houses foreclosing him.
Obama just pass that,
that bill.
What is that a month ago?
Was it though?
Um,
it's a good,
yeah,
I thought it was pretty good.
It sounded pretty good.
What does it do?
It just like,
uh,
it,
um,
there were a bunch of different facets of it,
but one of it was like your house can be foreclosed on,
um,
in the first three years.
Like if you served in the military,
like just things that you,
you were like,
this wasn't already a rule,
right?
Um,
yeah,
just like helping out the uh,
mental health when people get a chance.
Yeah,
totally.
Get,
try and get their house back.
I'm pro that.
Yeah.
This is terrible.
I need to know more about this.
I need to know more about this too,
but I'm what I'm reading right now,
it's fucking terrifying.
I just,
I,
I see all these things like the national defense authorization act and all these
different rules that all are going to allow them to have fucking drones in the
sky in the next 20 years.
Going to be 30,000 drones flying through the sky.
What's a drone flying machines that can take video and send back realtime data
and work on a four g connection or by that time,
you know,
seven or eight g whatever the fuck.
So much information in here.
I think ignorance is bliss.
I'm going to keep on being retired.
It's probably a good mood.
I agree.
You got to find that dude that doesn't have a job.
Who lucks
cool without a dude right now you guys think I just go home and I'm just like,
oh man
would have taken care of you with some good deck and you wouldn't have had that
food poisoning.
You think straighten.
Yeah.
Throw up once.
Get it all out of your system.
He pumps you fall.
Some hot lead's sweet,
energizes your back up.
Can you imagine if blokes actually energized you?
If like when we would be mad if he didn't fuck them because fight with a dude
again.
Yeah,
because that's the way you got God by.
Could you imagine if we needed each other that way?
Like we were like,
well,
you know,
like we'll give you hit the brakes on us.
One of those electric cars,
it actually recharges the battery.
Could you imagine if that's the way humans recharge?
We gotta fuck.
Like procreating is not enough for a six day together.
It's gotta be right.
More appealing.
What if we start evolving like that and that direction?
You know,
they say that people need physical attention.
You need,
you absolutely need affection from other people.
It's like we did our bodies like needed.
It desires it on a core level.
What if it turns into not just that,
but you actually need to fuck and then if you don't fuck your body just rots
away and dies and the only way to keep moving as if you have to have to fuck.
You have to fucking,
they're gay.
So you'd be mad.
[inaudible] I dunno.
With Gay Jazz,
probably like engineer do some genetic engineering on their loads so that they
figured out how a guy can absorb it through his ass.
We'd have to time it.
Right?
Like what if we go ahead and take a shit?
A Chevy shits out,
all the good sperm and then you don't evolve.
You got the timing on that.
Seriously.
It's not preposterous to think that we would need each.
I mean we need each other.
I mean we get it.
You know how you get addicted to sex,
right?
If you're in a relationship,
when you first started having sex,
especially right in the beginning,
don't you feel like it mixed all you think about.
Exactly.
You start thinking,
why don't we not?
When you can't wait to
get together with each other.
Yeah.
It's like a total drug.
Yeah,
it is like a turtle drug.
But that's one of the reasons why people are so angry when people leave them.
It's like you're taking my drug away,
taking my thing away.
Right.
What if it was even more intense than that?
And it literally got to a point where your body would register very obvious
changes whether or not you had a sperm inside your body withdrawal and whether a
guy got rid of it,
the guy has to get rid of it and it doesn't get rid of it.
Like he's,
it's burning him up,
you know,
not much different than reality.
I would rather die than have sex with anybody I've ever had sex with him ever in
the past.
Is there a one guy when you look
back and go,
that one could have worked out better?
Maybe I just fucking shut a one for that finger in the ass thing.
Did what he asked?
No,
I,
I've always gone for the finger in the ass.
Um,
but no.
Yeah,
no.
I ask you to do something creepy and you were like,
that swear I gotta go.
I don't know.
I think I've ever had anybody asked me something that was too creepy that I said
no,
a girl told me to fuck her client once.
I was like,
whoa.
It was just like,
Whoa,
what did it mean you?
Is that what you call it?
Just isn't that what it is?
I'm like,
Oh,
I mean
we change your terminology a little bit.
Seeing the,
I just,
I talked about this on,
I'm on o and a uh,
but I was like dirty texting with a guy and he like,
and I wrote something like,
um,
like I,
I was going to send on his face or something and like,
uh,
right.
And uh,
and he wrote back like,
all right,
but like oral is going to go both ways.
And I was just like,
what is this a negotiation like Douche Bro.
I think,
I think when it comes to like talking shit in the bedroom you like,
it's got to kind of be,
anything goes in unless it's complete insanity.
But I like if a guy's ever mentioned something I've said while having sex after,
I'm like,
are you fucking crazy?
Like not talk about that is a secret.
That was a circle of trust that you are like,
I would never be like,
wow,
at dinner after you fuck someone you talk shit.
You're like,
so I'm calling me a whore nonstop.
Like you gotta just,
you gotta just keep it,
keep it in there.
If something makes you uncomfortable,
you have to be like,
that's not cool.
Don't,
don't call me your sister.
Yeah.
What do you do if something like that happens?
You pull them aside,
like when you're having dinner or do like,
oh,
can I talk to you for a second?
Uh,
do you,
uh,
how do you write that ship?
Um,
uh,
I've just broken up with them.
It's work.
I had one guy,
the sex got too weird in what way?
We needed to watch.
He like,
he needed to watch me watch me
porn.
And at first it was like,
okay,
pretty high.
It was,
it was fun at first and then it was like,
that's all he wanted to do.
He wanted to catch me watching porn,
Ooh and Aah and then have sex while I watched porn and like it was fun.
It is kind
of hard,
but I don't like the catching you.
I just want you to,
what if it's like creepy porn was poor with girls who tits are just way too big
and they stretch out and you see the bag.
Every time they went to him with his dad,
it was like pretty,
pretty normal run of the mill.
It's hard doing regular normal porn.
Everybody wants to throw up and gagged spitting and assholes.
It's hard finding regular porn these days.
Oh,
it's easy to Harley.
I see a lot of gagging because a lot of
what?
When did that become the fucking normal move
and have the girls isn't even on it.
They're not even,
they can't really close it mouth cause the guy's kind of fucking the back of
their throat.
Spoiler alert,
she's going to get a load on her face.
This one,
they're all the same.
Well sometimes they do what they call cream pies.
That's very popular now.
What does that,
that's like when they showed it inside the pussy orgasms in the girl's pussy and
it just works it out.
And there's anal cream pies and pies.
Yeah there's oral cream pies.
Got To be a strong man to date one of those girls.
Like I never watched the end of a porn.
Yeah I never get to know I need the do you watch porn by yourself or you always
would really do watch porn cause you're excited by it cause a lot of girls are
not.
You are
still figuring myself out a little bit.
Porn when I was younger I was like I,
I was living with a boyfriend and like he would watch porn and I was like see
that he had like left on the computer and I would be like that's like cheating
on me and I was young and dumb and a and then this poor guy cause now I like
love porn.
Have you ever thought about doing like the AVN awards?
Like hosting that?
I was supposed to host this like escort awards this year for like hookers.
Yeah
guys.
But they have an award show was in New York and I supposed to host escorts.
I must be gay.
Right before they set up.
I think they saw my standup and fired me.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know they but they,
uh,
they were like,
oh,
we decided not to have a comic or will,
they probably saw it.
They probably saw you and thought this bitch is going to talk about those.
And then there was 10 minutes in her act.
You would for sure though.
I would have,
I was so excited.
The money wasn't a great,
I was like,
oh,
of course I'll do it.
I think they tried to insult me with how low the offer was.
I was like,
nice try.
I'm like,
I'm going to be there doing it or no,
no.
They said they didn't want to come back kind of at the last minute.
They're probably scared of it's high,
but I would have this,
is this before or after the roast?
After.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is just supposed to be,
they probably just didn't sell enough tickets.
Awesome.
Oh,
I doubt it.
No doubt.
Have annual events freaks and they,
they'd probably,
someone said,
do you realize that you're opening up the gates of hell?
Do you realize that by exposing our award show to this comedian who gets to go
on national television and talk about us?
Yeah,
there must be a lot of confidentiality.
Was Paul Lynde sort of angry gay guy?
Just I um,
I don't know.
Like I like that whole industry cause I really don't judge us.
Mail,
hip or industry,
just like sex industry and strippers,
like a male hooker industries.
The dots are dark wing of that world.
I wonder what do you remember like when there's a guy who got caught who was a
White House press correspondent or White House press reporter who got caught,
what you got caught?
It turned out that he was running a gay porn site.
Uh,
gay,
uh,
excuse me,
gay escort site,
like military,
a game,
military escort site.
I remember that.
His name was,
I believe his name is Jeff Gannon.
And he would,
uh,
he would lob these really s like underhand slow pitch statement questions to the
president,
depression of Bush at the time.
Mr. Bush,
Mr President,
when are the Democrats going to get their head out of that
sand?
Realize any that like literally he was a reporter and people would go,
fuck is Bush wanted him in there every time he would get it was his go to guy of
course.
And he is,
he actually stayed at the White House.
This guy had slept over at the White House and he turned out he had some gay
military escort website where it was him lying there naked with like a,
like a towel over his deck wearing a dog tag.
I am,
yeah.
It's all just about sucking Dick as a soldier and taking in the military.
He said depressing and flow.
But this guy didn't him and they don't know what the fuck that was all about.
Who was,
who was the,
you know,
was it Ken Starr mean?
Who Was it?
Um,
which one of those,
those guys?
It was the,
the gay guy.
There was another guy that's the,
uh,
the guy who was the mastermind for bushes campaign.
I,
what the fuck is his name?
The man behind.
I just wanted to j Edgar and that,
that gate hot,
that movie.
It was boom.
It was,
it was boring.
But I liked like,
uh,
I,
I've,
I don't get turned on by gay dudes having sex with each other,
but I would have liked to have seen them have sex with each other.
You would have liked to have seen those guys.
I would love to see Leo and an Army Hammer.
You serious?
Please?
I don't care who's bending who over.
I'm watching.
Are you going to do a town Wednesday?
Yeah.
Do you want to do the comedy show here at the Ice House?
Do I have to drive here again?
No,
just kidding.
Um,
yeah.
Can I,
yeah,
sure.
Nine o'clock.
Okay.
Karl Rove.
Oh yeah.
What was really Super Gay and he,
uh,
hell no chicks.
I'm just making this up by the way.
Karl.
I could be totally wrong.
Please don't send me,
Carlos loves this pocket.
I don't know who the fuck it was that was gay.
Let's just say that.
I have no
idea.
I'm just totally guessing out of my ass.
But whoever it was,
somebody knew this guy.
And somebody got this Guy Gig there and that guy turned out to be a
madam and it was deep in the White House in there.
And Yeah,
I guess people back then just thought,
wow,
the internet so big,
who's going to find this?
They didn't understand the search search engines.
Yeah.
Shit.
That'll catch up to you.
You're in the White House.
I guess they all managing thinking that you just get to pull that off.
Like,
you know,
gay,
I score,
stay at the White House.
No one's going to know how they gonna know.
Fuck Dude,
I know that guy.
Oh Man.
I think about the things they pulled off before the Internet.
Oh yeah.
Oh my.
Well they say that Nixon was gay.
A guy just wrote a book about Nixon being gay.
Every,
there's a photo of him with this smaller Hispanic man who was with a small dog,
you know,
which by the way,
you have a small dog,
you either bad motherfucker or you might be gay.
I mean,
back then in those days you do the tiny dog.
That's tough too.
Maybe.
Or maybe you know,
maybe he's a bad motherfucker.
Like my friend mayhem,
his MMA fighter,
he's got a a Datsun hotdog,
chocolate Dell when he was the UFC light heavyweight champion.
He always had this little Chihuahua.
He took everywhere,
but he was such a bad motherfucker.
He could totally pull off.
Really?
That was also a lot of gay guys walking around with a dog in a purse.
I lost mine in a divorce.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I mean I got mine.
I don't like the people in la are like,
he's beautiful dogs.
You could just see that they're just using them as like an accessory.
That dog is supposed to represent them.
They liked the way it looks.
And a woman with a dog is not alone.
She's busy and with my dog.
Come on honey.
We gotta go.
Sorry.
You think you were going always.
We just fucking be an adult.
Real woman with a dog is,
is,
is two people.
It's like she can we it where she can get away.
Excuse me,
I'm busy.
I have to walk my dog got into a relationship with someone.
You're like,
oh good.
She's distracted.
But up top.
That's got to be tapped into.
If like you've used tardies.
Boring ass conversation.
Yeah.
I just want you here.
Go play with your dog.
Yeah.
And then get ready to be alone with the dog.
When I come around to slink deck.
Did you tell our con no.
Has anybody ever said to you be ready when I come home and slink deck?
No.
That sounds good though.
I think I want to say that.
Really?
No.
Nobody right that to me on Twitter.
Of course I'm going to get a hundred course sticks.
Yeah,
it's in,
it's inevitable now.
Yeah.
I'm coming home to slink tech that's coming.
That's going to be,
that's all.
I'm going to be someone's new signature on a message board.
That's a cut.
That's what happened.
So like I'll forget that we said this and then I'll be in Denver and some dude
will come up after the show and be like,
how about we get,
I'll sleep and I'll be like,
I'm calling the cops
rapist.
What?
How does that really happens?
That seems like it would happen a lot.
That happens all the time.
Yeah.
I mean,
how much crazy shit the last time.
Crazy people that tweet you after you did the last one.
Yeah.
Mostly not crazy people.
Nice people were really nice.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I'm back.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm sensitive
and I'm back.
Uh,
yeah.
No,
like it was nice and people like will come up and they'll say like,
oh,
I'm a,
I'm a fan of Rogan's podcast.
And that's how I found you.
People like to say how they found you.
Yeah.
You know?
Well,
the,
the like to
profess the,
he liked that they liked something that they hope you like it
to like,
yeah.
You all know.
And A,
and I'll go off fucking level when they're right.
And then we're all on a party rock.
Right?
Yeah.
You,
if somebody likes that,
you'll,
you know,
like that you can kind of connect on other shit.
Yeah.
Y'All,
I mean,
it's like if someone's a fan of a particular team,
you know,
you walk up to a guy and he's wearing a Celtics jacket.
Yeah.
I Love Laurie Burn.
I like met fans.
I'm like,
you're really a person.
Do you think you'd,
you'd think about dating a professional baseball player or would that be too
much pressure?
Uh,
I don't know.
I went out with a couple athletes lately.
Yeah.
It seems like,
I don't know.
I think they need like a cheerleader and like unbusy oh yeah.
I'm very,
especially if they're like super driven and concentrating on that goal.
I like that,
but I don't,
I don't want them to need me to be like [inaudible] they're like,
we'll come to the game.
Yeah.
Like 14 colors.
I made a dress for you.
You know,
I only win when you wear pink.
What did you where Magenta?
I'm like,
I have a show.
I have to do radio.
Your shows more important than my game.
Yes.
Yeah.
I don't fucking show up what your game,
I don't want to like learn the rules of a new sport.
Yeah.
What if you had a date,
a cricket player?
Oh my God.
Doing out there.
It's so funny.
So that was talking to a dude.
Really.
I'm not interested in,
I don't want to learn about cricket.
Is He English?
Australian.
Oh,
Australia.
They play cricket two and then weird an India I think.
And that's it.
India.
I was in Saint Lucia.
They were all going fucking crazy.
Where exactly is that on the map?
Um,
it's like gee,
it's in like the West indies.
It's just wow.
It's by how long has that on a plane?
It was six from New York.
Ooh.
Yeah.
And then we took a helicopter to our hotel to our couples.
Now I can love chamber
those,
that area.
Like if you go down like The Bahamas,
Jamaica,
yeah,
he'd go like,
and the Atlantic,
South Atlantic.
You got to worry about storms.
Yeah.
Not this was not the season,
but there's like five months where if you go there you're just like,
I hope,
I don't know,
five months where there's a lot of tourists that go there because it's less
money and you take some wild chances.
They're so aggressive though because like the tourist only come for a couple
months.
So every,
we did a ton of shit.
We like hiked this crazy mountain and we would go to like these bags.
We did all this stuff and every time you leave the hotel,
they're like,
just trying to sell you a fucking necklace.
And you're like,
no,
but they need to come at you that hard.
Cause that's all they got.
Yeah.
It's all they have and the guy's a hit on you.
They're like,
that's a whole other ballgame.
They're so aggressive and they're hoping that you either have like white guilt
or that you're scared of black people.
And I've,
I'm neither.
So I was just like,
like what do they do?
They just come at you and like,
yeah,
like they just dance.
Like they're going to be mad at you
if you don't give me an example.
Like what's the accent?
Like?
Oh,
like I can't,
I have no idea.
I can't.
Oh,
your dialect coach keeps chiming in with flawless intonation cartoons.
I feel like you were made by a computer dom.
My rera couldn't figure him out.
Where'd you get him?
Where'd you get this gun?
Has all the people in the world?
Well,
we're just talking about islanders.
Really sweet people.
Then what is the accent?
It's like a Jamaican type thing.
So gimme like black guy comes up to what's,
what's going on?
How's he doing?
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I'm so not giving him.
He's like ready to play.
Would you like to buy some weed?
Brian?
Brian is,
what do we do it like what do we do
right here,
man on an island.
Good Dick Right here.
That's good.
Is that what it is to grab their dicks so they dance in front of you.
Grabbing like Michael Jackson style.
Nothing.
How often does this take place during your travels then?
We left the hotel really,
but there were some people,
there were Great Dick Grammars
carnival cruises also because I would imagine that would be the same
sandals.
All couples.
Those are what did you see any families?
Their
kids a lot.
How old can the kid be?
Can it be 18 no children,
but then they can drink down there.
If it's 18 they have crazy drinking loss,
bring it on the street like New Orleans.
New Orleans is amazing like that.
And then there's one place in America that I say you should have,
you should have to have a passport to go to New Orleans.
This just not America.
People walking on the street with beers in their hands right by cops and the
cops are talking to them and everybody's,
everybody's friendly.
Such a good vibe.
[inaudible]
special in New Orleans,
but I can time it right,
like timing sucked.
But that,
that place is amazing.
Friendly and fun.
And I did a show there.
I did the House of Blues.
There was one of my favorite all time.
Yeah,
we went to and then we watched some burlesque.
What a,
what a hustle that is.
What a nonsense hustle.
Those burlesque shows are.
Well one of them of them,
it was
really weird.
Like there was a guy like a carnival barker dude comes on,
he's got a big handlebar mustache and he's dressed kind of crazy.
Like he's from another time,
there was a couple people that actually had a pretty dope act and one of them,
there was a guy and a girl and they had like little Hula hoops and um,
the,
the guy would,
uh,
throw the girl up in the end,
she would land on her shoulders that she would have.
It was,
it was really a great act.
And they were like Hula Hoop and together while the girl was on top and the guy
was like holding her up with his hands.
It,
they knew what the fuck they would do and they had planned it out.
Yeah.
And then the next one was literally an overweight woman who dances and the guy
introduces her saying that beautiful things come at all,
literally said this.
She like really David.
And she wasn't obese.
It wasn't like disgusting where he had a warrant.
Ours is not hiring her.
Yeah,
no scores is not hiring.
Right.
And so she gets up there and she's got this bright smile on her face and it's
like,
it's like this weird thing that everyone's dressed from like a period piece,
but essentially all she did was stand there and dance.
So it was the emperor's new clothes.
She took a little bit of the clothes off at the end.
She was kind of in like sort of a bikini type of thing and then she got off and
everybody clapped and I'm like,
fuck,
really?
I'm like,
what is going on?
Why are we pretending like that was exciting,
real weird.
And we were complaining,
I'm sorry.
We were complaining about and the people around us are getting upset.
We had to leave.
Oh really?
Everybody else's lives are complaining and you were like,
there's a man behind that curtain.
He's pulling the levers.
We can see it from here.
Exactly.
This is not real.
I'm glad you said something while we were just like,
what is this?
Yeah,
like it just,
you just like truth.
You're just like,
can we not pretend like that was something that should happen again?
Well,
it was a two.
It was two,
two comics in me.
It was me,
Dunkin and Felicia Michaels.
Yeah.
And uh,
Jeff,
who was our driver in New Orleans,
who's cool as fuck too.
Yeah.
And we'll,
we're all,
you know,
we're all looking at this going,
what the fuck are we watching?
What is this?
Oh,
this is nonsense.
But that second place,
the food,
Oh yes.
Food anywhere.
Did your,
I went to Amsterdam and we went to a sex show.
Oh shoot.
Did you see though,
have you seen those top notes on what you saw?
It will,
they were really depressing.
It was like totally clinical.
Um,
so be like,
there was a DJ and then like a bed would be wheeled out on stage.
It would be like this French guy.
And he's like,
Zec is,
uh,
um,
Michelle and her lover Mat and then a,
and they kind of like both come out in the bed and then they're like,
they wave and then they like start like,
um,
like a second of kind of like foreplay that's choreographed.
And then they start fucking like,
he starts fucking her.
And the bed's rotating and it's to music and he's banging her to the beat.
And then,
uh,
and then after like three minutes,
they're like,
thank you.
And um,
and then they turned to the crowd and they wave and the curtain closes and the
bag goes.
And then this girl would come out in between.
I'm in between people having sex and like kind of like a burlesque,
like type strep or she's Kinda hot,
like high school friend hot.
And she didn't really know what she was doing.
She,
she danced like she was for like the palm squad,
so she'd be in like a bra and underwear and she would just be like,
like just kind of dancing around.
And it was interesting.
It was like kind of interesting to watch,
but it just,
nothing was sexy about the whole experience.
And then somebody in a gorilla suit comes out,
um,
with a fake dick and s word sit on the crowd.
That was a whole show that was all show.
But there was a couple of home visits.
Like what was the time?
Uh,
I think it was like an hour.
So the other stuff was just like filler.
Yeah.
Filler between people having sex.
Wow.
But the DJ was pretty funny.
Like they were funny with each other and they were like,
thank you.
Oh,
she's back from her tour of the,
you know,
it was just,
it was all kind of like ironic,
but there was not a second of anything sensual or exciting.
Wow.
I think,
I wonder if they do that on purpose.
Like nobody,
there would've been no one was taking their dick out.
I think it was just like,
maybe that's probably exactly what they're doing.
Yeah.
They had a show at the Riviera.
They should do call crazy girl.
But still there.
Is it still there?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That,
who's who's hosting it now?
I don't know.
Let me see.
There we have is so funny.
We were just,
um,
I don't stay there.
Um,
but we were just in a record store before I start puking my guts out listening
to old comedy albums and Totie fields had one and it starts,
it's like live from the Riviera.
I mean,
Jackie were so psyched.
And Woody Allen,
ed one,
like there's a lot of history at that,
at that place,
but yet crazy girls is up and running.
Dean Martin was a host of front.
Wow.
Frank Sinatra and Dean Martin used to do shows.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Stayed in Frank Sinatra.
Sweet once at Harris,
my friend Steve Sherpa.
Oh,
Steve Shrimp.
I used to run the know used to be the booker.
Yeah.
He uh,
yeah.
It's such a,
it's like such a horrible old Vegas showroom.
Yeah.
Steve Sherpas.
Great Story.
I mean,
he was a guy who was,
uh,
the talent coordinator at the Riviera and then all of sudden he got on
soprano's.
Yeah.
And then it turns into a real career as an actor writing books and shirts.
Nuts.
Yeah.
I don't,
it doesn't see,
it doesn't say here who the host is crazy girls.
It's,
they're not advertising who the host is at the hotel.
Oh,
really?
It's just like crazy girls
used to be,
but what do they do?
I've never,
I haven't gone in,
uh,
well it's like girls,
they sing songs and then they pulled her tits out.
Oh.
And some of them actually have,
uh,
they actually have pretty good sense.
Okay.
Well they're good tests,
but some of them actually have talent.
And A,
I watched it once and it was,
it was kind of sad because this girl was singing like,
um,
a Whitney Houston song.
It was like the greatest love of all or something like that right after when you
died?
No,
as long time ago.
Uh,
for the moment.
Sure.
Psychic.
She woke up in the middle of the night.
He'll set up in bed
nailing and murdered Whitney.
Oh,
that was a cover by the way.
We did a cover,
I might not even been that song,
but whatever song it was,
should we,
this song,
very soulful
song.
And she has her tits out and I'm like,
wow,
that's gotta be kind of demeaning in a way.
It's like really weird.
It's like she's singing at the top of her.
I mean,
she's singing the best of her abilities.
She's actually a talented singer,
but her tits are out and she's got like a sort of like a mini skirt dress on and
her tits are out and you can tell that she wants to be taken seriously as a
singer.
But she's saying let her tits out.
Okay.
It's horrible.
That's really sad.
It was weird.
It was just weird.
It says so much sadness.
Yes.
Deep Sadness.
They have those,
um,
at the imperial palace.
They've dealer Tanner's what?
Wait,
did I cut you off?
No.
Okay.
You're still doing this for the year.
I'm like,
oh,
is he still talking about her tits?
No.
Yeah,
there's what they have or the,
the dealers are all dressed like celebrity celebrities,
dealer detainers and your,
so your dealer,
like every hour they'll like be like some signal in there like,
oh,
sorry.
And so the guy dresses like Michael Jackson or a girl's Rihanna,
and they have to like stand on the stage and like do an act and sing and then
they come back and uh,
at first you're like,
it's kind of funny.
And then it gets so sad,
so fast.
Are we going?
Yeah.
You're just like,
ah.
And then you just want to gamble.
You're like,
oh,
can you please stop with all the bullshit?
Just like,
let's do this.
Wow.
Yeah.
Like who was your guy?
We had Michael Jackson and then I think maybe Shania twain or Miley Cyrus.
It actually looked like Michael Jackson.
He was white.
Well,
that's a tricky one because you can hire a black guy to do it.
I know.
That's real.
You got to know from a lot of,
what do you do?
Yeah.
There's not a real likeness to any of them.
Like you spend half the time trying to figure out who they are.
Like you're like,
is that Bonnie Raitt
Boy George or whoever.
Now
it's a really tough,
all right,
let's bring this fucking ship into the harbor.
Alright,
Schumer once again.
You were hilarious.
I'm glad.
We're besties for life.
We're besties.
We exchanged messages.
You're my emergency contacts
buddy.
So happy you came back.
He'd love you.
I love you.
When are you going to be,
um,
what's,
what's your,
um,
your tour dates?
It's fine.
The next time I'm in Tampa and Denver,
the end of April.
And then the Riviera tons of when,
when are you in Tampa?
Like towards the end of April?
Yeah,
like so Amy Schumer,
[inaudible]
dot com and it's Schumer with an s c h s c h a m e s.
C h.
E m.
E.
R.
I m still selling tickets for a Atlanta.
The second show's not sold out yet.
So the Tabernacle on April 20th where I'm filming my new special,
I'm going to be releasing an online first show sold out and a fucking pumped to
be doing in Atlanta.
Man,
I haven't been there in two years and I'm super psyched and I'm completely
geared up for this bitch.
And a next year or next week rather is,
um,
the final stage I'm going to be at the Fort Lauderdale Improv with,
they want an only Duncan Trussell.
So that'll be this upcoming Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
It's not next week.
If this,
this next weekend,
this weekend coming up.
So this weekend,
Fort Lauderdale,
next weekend on the 20th is Atlanta and that's when I'm going to be taping my
special Ed day before the UFC in Atlanta.
We have a show here Wednesday night at nine o'clock at the ice house,
another wild tuneup show before we escape to Florida,
before the race riot kicks in to hear the shooting at cop cars down there now.
Yeah.
That's where the Trayvon Martin shooting happened.
They killed Florida.
Florida's going crazy.
I don't know what part I'll have to get back to you with that information.
Thank you to the fleshlight for sponsoring our program.
Please go to Joe rogan.net if you're,
um,
thinking about masturbating and go pick up one of those cause it's way better
than just using your hand.
Uh,
entering the code name Brogan,
save yourself 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
It's a solid product that he's a gentlemen.
Thank you also to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune and new mood.
Both,
um,
shroom techs or,
well,
it was different things.
Different things do different things.
There's,
some of them are nootropics,
other ones are,
um,
athletic enhancement supplements and um,
maybe they'd be performance enhancing drugs.
Maybe you could say that.
I wonder if there'll be illegal someday.
Get them out before the government comes in and takes all the shit that makes
you feel better.
Everything is a performance enhancing drug.
Dude,
even fucking vitamins.
Did you know that Brian?
It helps you perform.
It's a God damn performance enhancer.
Uh,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for Alpha brain and entering the code name Rogan and save
yourself 10% off any and all orders as always,
the first order of 30 pills,
the bottle 30 pills is 100% money back guarantee.
If you're not satisfied,
if you don't like it,
you don't even have to return it.
Just tell us that shit sucks and you get your money,
but it won't suck or use it.
This shit is awesome and you should use it too.
Especially if you have a,
if you're jet lagged or hung over and I know you are on a regular dirty you
dirty bitch or if he can't cope without the Teede.
Uh,
I don't think that's true.
I think the,
the you got to eat the actual cordyceps mushroom.
I don't know if it actually helps you cope without the two.
I don't want to put any false statements.
Brian.
I want to do the research on that before I confirm or deny cope with Whitney
Houston.
Altitude sucks dude.
Nothing is going to help you.
It might help you a little like,
Ugh,
that's the end of this program.
God dammit.
We'll be back tomorrow with a Neal Brennan.
Uh,
it'll be a 4:00 PM Pacific podcasts and um,
and then uh,
I'll see you dirty bitches in Fort Lauderdale this weekend in Atlanta.
Next week chronicles Amy Schumer is going to do so.
Show was crazy as fuck you going to do the show as well.
God Damn it.
What a fucking show.
It's me.
Amy Schumer.
Who else?
So surprises a bunch of the surprises.
We'll probably will stop.
A lot of la comics is always the,
the,
the regular crew.
I know Joe.
He's got a 10 o'clock at the implant.
You can't do it.
Can't do it.
You dirty bitch.
All right folks.
That's it.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Thank you.
As always,
for everything.
Thanks for all the positive messages and all the love and all the good shit,
and we're all in this together and freaks.
Let's ride this thing.
Fucking boat hits the beach.